Beep beep, where'd the music go?
I think it doesn't loop.
It was playing this whole time.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome!
Hey, y'all.
Howdy.
Congratulations on the five-year streaming.
Thank you!
Well, five-year streaming this... this... thur... thursday.
Yeah, this thursday.
Thank you!
Um, we will... we will do a thing on thursday.
And I will have an announcement.
An announcement!
Oh, what could it be?
Let's shake it, baby.
We looked lonely until Minto's streamed.
Yeah.
A thing, a thing, a thing.
Can I get a birthday shout-out?
Your pal, Mai!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday, Mai!
Welcome, everybody, to Blade Runner.
It's very quiet.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know why the music... it doesn't loop.
Sorry.
Um...
But, uh... this is an old... 90s game.
It's retro... we're retro gaming.
We're retro gaming today!
Are you tabbed in?
I absolutely am.
And for some reason, the sensitivity on the mouse is so... slow.
So, hopefully... it improves in the game.
But this is like an old... an old... uh... point and click.
Congrats on five years.
Don't congrats me yet!
It's not yet!
But thank you.
That's when I arrived.
Thank you!
Thank you for ordering it!
Digital woman, why are you digital?
90s is old now.
You have to... you have to come with ter... to ter...
You have to come to terms now.
The 90s are retro.
It's... it's... it's... it's not your fault.
It's just how time works.
You have to come to terms with it.
No, I'm young!
Right.
2015 is retro?
Okay, wait a second.
That's like only 10 years ago.
Um... thank you for all the zippernets!
Sorry, I can't read them!
Oh, hold on.
I could tab out and read some...
Before I start.
Um...
Finally gets Seiya on global.
Now JPS swimsuit Seiya.
I know!
Sudaku Wiz, thank you for the...
Super chat.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I...
Oh gosh.
Thank you so much for all the super chats!
Thank you guys!
I am very...
I'm... I'm very extremely slow-brained today.
I... I actually... I was like, I'll start a little bit early of a stream.
So that I can play for longer.
And...
I was like, maybe I could even beat the game today.
When I first made my schedule.
And now my brain...
Oh gosh.
I'm so...
Eepy sleepy today.
I...
I woke up...
No.
Yesterday, I went to sleep at...
10...
10 p.m.
It wasn't so...
Early.
Uh...
8 p.m.
or 10 p.m.
I can't remember.
My sleep schedule has been wackadoodle lately.
And...
Um...
But I woke up...
At 3 a.m.
because it's the haunting hour.
And basically, every day, I've been waking up at 3 a.m.
I wake up at 3 a.m.
Uh...
But this time, I was having allergy attack.
And so I took allergy medicine.
And it had antihistamine in it.
Which just...
Which effs me up.
And now...
The whole day, I've been like...
A zombie.
A zombie!
I'm supposed to be a ghost!
And I'm a zombie!
Epee epee baby.
Yes.
Reminder that PS3 is almost 20 years old.
PS4 is 12 years old.
PS3 is almost 20?
It can almost drink?
In the US?
Mito, that's me!
This game was made by Westwood.
Who were most well known for making...
RTS games like Command and Conquer.
They're super talented.
Really excited for this game.
It's really, really cool.
You had to bomb me though.
Thank you!
I was saying...
That I would play this game a lot...
When I was a wee wisp.
I was a wee wisp.
And I would play this game...
With my papa...
Papa Ghost.
And...
He would play this game all the time.
Even though I was a wee wisp...
I still remember so many things about this game.
But I never got to play it myself.
I was always so...
I was always too scared to play it.
It's kind of creepy, you know?
This game.
It's kind of creepy.
But I remember like the most abstract things about this game.
Like I know we're gonna start at a pet shop.
I know that.
And I know sometimes you go to a restaurant.
And then I know sometimes I...
Uh...
There...
I remember the aesthetic of big shadows on the walls.
Of big fans turning.
With their shadows turning on the walls.
And then I remember a guy who makes puppets.
Um...
And that area scared me a lot.
A lot!
And...
Um...
What else do I remember?
I think that's all I remember.
I remember...
This...
Thing...
Traveling...
To and from...
With...
With this thing.
With our floaty car.
And...
Yeah...
I just...
I remember locations.
And I don't remember any of the story.
Um...
So...
I'll probably...
If you guys...
Played this before.
And you're just like...
Oh, I remember this.
I will...
I will also be like...
Oh my gosh!
I remember this!
So...
Um...
Did you watch the movies?
You know, I...
Watched...
Probably...
The original Blade Runner.
So, so long ago.
I don't remember it.
But I watched the new one.
The new...
The...
The one that...
I watched it.
I watched it because so many people were memeing it.
So I wanted to watch it.
Why...
People were memeing it.
So...
Arigato!
Chuuu!
Thank you!
Happy 5 year anniversary!
It's not my 5 year anniversary yet!
But thank you.
You guys are too early!
Yeah...
The original...
The original is Harrison Ford, no?
So of course I would love it.
Yeah, with...
With the...
The new one...
What is it?
20-40...
Something.
20...
40...
Something.
Happy your doctor said your throat was looking better.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, yesterday I was able to...
Record a cover that I had been putting off for many, many months.
So I was really happy...
That I was able to finally get it done.
And so many things have been on the back burner because of my throat.
So...
Finally, I'm catching up to things.
It's nice to play games that your parents played with you.
My dad never played anything.
My dad played a lot of games.
And I would...
I would sit and watch.
I was...
I was a daddy girl.
I...
Um...
Always played games and stuff.
Or watched my dad play games.
He played like...
Like he uh...
Age of Empires.
He always played that.
And uh...
Neverwinter Nights.
He always played that.
And uh...
Tomb Raider.
He always played that.
So...
Yeah!
Speaking of the 90s, I recently acquired Slayers.
Oh!
I finished it today.
I loved it.
Now I'm sad because I want more Slayers.
But isn't Slayers...
I feel like Slayers was one of those...
Shows that felt very long.
I never watched it though.
But the opening is a bop.
Love Neverwinter Nights.
Oh my gosh.
My...
He...
We even had like...
I guess he got the special edition.
And we had like a little...
It came with like a map.
Of like...
Where to go.
Like you know...
A map of the...
Of the city.
All I remember for Neverwinter Nights is the plague at the very beginning.
And how that was my favorite part of the game.
Was watching everybody die.
In the beginning.
And Draco's...
Wait.
It doesn't say how many gifted memberships you gave.
But thank you.
Thank you so much.
But it came with like a little map of the...
Of the...
Of the city.
And my dad would be like...
Okay Mint.
Where do I go next?
And I'd be like...
Okay Dad.
You go here.
Did I use the map?
To tell him where to go.
Even though he already knew.
Because he played the game a bajillion times.
He loved Diablo 2.
Not Diablo 2.
I mean he did play Diablo 2.
But he loved Diablo.
Yeah.
So.
Did he ever give you an unplugged controller to pretend you're playing?
No.
My dad played more PC games than anything.
I didn't really play.
Yeah.
Eventually he got into like Call of Duty.
And something else.
I can't remember.
There was...
There was some other game.
That was like...
Ugh.
I can't remember.
Tragic.
I don't think he...
I don't think he like was online.
Or...
You know.
He didn't...
He...
You know.
It was...
Oh yeah.
The pirate game.
Sid Meier's Pirates.
Yeah.
He loved that game too.
Sorry.
I'm just going over memory lane now.
I'll run the win.
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
You're walking through a desert.
And you see a turtle flipped over.
On its back in the hot sun.
What do you do?
Flip...
Flip it over?
Yeah.
Anyway.
We should get started.
We'll see how long I go for this.
Because...
I...
Like I said...
I might...
I might get really excited.
And...
And start feeling better.
But...
Right now I'm so...
Honk.
Me, me, me, me, me.
So...
Yeah.
Okie dokie!
Lance Gaou.
New game.
Difficulty...
What's...
I guess...
What's the...
My personality?
What's a sur...
Don't call me Shirley.
Erratic...
User choice.
I'm polite.
I'm demure.
Wait, what?
This is crazy.
I guess I'll try normal for the base experience.
What is a user's choice?
What if I want to be evil?
Erotic?
No!
Oh my gosh.
Card zero.
Thank you so much.
My other day was my birthday.
Happy birthday!
What is this game about?
It's Blade Runner.
Based off the movie.
Wait, do we want to be erotic?
You get to the crime scene and you're just like, what seems to be the problem here, officer?
And then...
And then you strip.
Robot women come.
Normal is the least fitting personality for you.
Yeah, but...
How...
What is a user's choice?
This is what...
This is the one that makes me most curious.
It's running in parallel to the plot of Blade Runner 1.
Yeah!
This is not Harrison Ford.
I don't know who this guy is.
Mint is joy and we're all the Ryan to her gosling.
What does that...
She Ryan on my gosling till I bing bong.
Okay.
This is not Ryan Reynolds.
This is old man.
Oh, I forgot to mention, I'm playing the enhanced version but I will...
I put it on the classic graphics.
So we'll see how that works.
Hopefully there's no issues.
It's your anniversary.
Happy anniversary.
It's not my anniversary!
But thank you.
She Ryan on my gosling till I Reynolds.
She's erotic, thinks erotic.
I didn't think erotic.
You guys did.
Okay, I'll just go with normal.
What does Shirley mean?
Hold on, I'm gonna look this up.
Shirley, don't call me Shirley.
Meaning.
Bad-tempered and unfriendly.
That's why they don't want to be called Shirley.
Oh, I see.
It means that you're an asshole.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna look this up.
It's gonna bother me.
Blade Runner game user choice personality.
Okay, we get a Steam page.
What does player personality do?
Oh, it's different lines of dialogue.
Oh, I kind of want to be a jerk.
I kind of want to be an asshole.
Be like, get out of my way.
Get out of my way.
User choice gives you more dialogue.
Oh, maybe that's good then.
We can kind of form our own character.
Maybe we try user choice then.
We can be grumpy.
Maybe some days we wake up on the wrong side of the bed.
Some days we're just a happy camper.
All right.
Skip toggle graphics.
Early in the 21st century, the Tyrell Corporation advanced robot evolution into the Nexus phase.
A being virtually identical to a human known as a replicant.
The Nexus 6 replicants were superior in strength and agility and at least equal in intelligence to the genetic engineers who created them.
Replicants were used off-world as slave labor in the hazardous exploration and colonization of other planets.
After a bloody mutiny by a Nexus 6 combat team in an off-world colony, replicants were declared illegal on Earth under penalty of death.
Special police squads' Blade Runner units had orders to shoot and kill upon detection any trespassing replicant.
This was not called execution.
It was called retirement.
Los Angeles, November 2019!
Ah, that's the LA.
I know and love modern-day LA.
It's too real!
Why are they copying Snatcher?
No!
Wasn't Snatcher inspired by this?
Big Tungus, thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Lady!
It's the pet sword!
I'm leaving now.
Lucy, my sweet.
I cleaned out the tiger cage and sorted all the meal bins.
Now that's a work uniform.
If it's alright, it's my turn to fix dinner.
Uh, uh, haven't you forgotten something, little one?
Just one little thing.
One day.
Let the lady go home!
It's a very long day.
Oh god, he's holding that- I don't want to.
He's clutching that bird.
No, Lucy, I thought we'd settled this last week.
Don't let's forget who pays your salary.
Yeah, he is.
We're closed.
Come back tomorrow.
LA to a team.
I haven't finished with you.
Those llamas?
I told you, we're closed.
We're not here to buy, little man.
We've come to sell.
Oh.
You can't possibly have anything to interest me.
Why is he gripping that bird?
These are extremely rare.
Let him go!
Of the highest quality.
Oh yeah, the llamas are so rare.
What a coincidence.
So am I.
Why is this game so...
Everything is so quiet.
Not my animals.
Please.
I'm begging you.
No.
But what of honor, little man.
At what price?
Honor.
Oh my god, no.
That tiger is the rarest specimen I've ever seen.
Tiger, tiger burning bright.
In the voice of the night.
VR61661 reports a preceptive...
Were you sleeping and driving?
I was just finishing up my 12 out on patrol when I got the call.
No, you were sleeping.
Welcome relief, considering that the most action I've seen all night was a schizo and grandmother doing the shimmy on her underwear in the second sector.
Sorry for keeping that up for so long.
Auto-pilot.
Sure, sure.
Let me know if I need to turn the audio up though.
I might be adjusting it throughout the stream.
You're naked grandma.
Code three, repeat code three.
Not the code three.
The last time I had a three was when some hooker vomited Thunderbird on Bryant's desk, and yours truly led the cleanup crew.
A year and a half on the job, it was still the dirtiest work I'd seen.
Where's Captain Bryant?
Took a sick day.
Got himself an anus case of Tomei, though, isn't he?
He asked me personally to run the unit in his absence.
Guza was one of the old-time guys who took their knocks in the streets.
He had a friendly way about him, but you didn't want to turn your back on him if you were less than a friend.
Hope you've been enjoying your leisure time, kid.
Because it's time to take that thumb out of your ass.
Hallelujah.
Don't get too excited.
The other Blade Runners are all jammed up.
Holden's sucking dinner through a straw.
Gaff's working the Tyrell break-in and Steele's working special undercover.
Looks like you got this one by default.
You really know how to make a girl feel wanted.
Animal murder down at Runciter Zoologic.
Animal murder!
I'll just be a schizoid glitz, but we got the call.
Old man Runciter lost something like a billion Chinions worth.
Ten to one, this ain't a job for Rep Detect.
You got something better to do?
Perfect your French cooking, maybe?
He's such a jerk.
Whoa, the lighting is crazy.
It's exactly what I remember.
I thought you were on special assignment.
Hot lady.
Wasn't too damn special after I had the suckers out.
What happened?
A couple of fours were masquerading as fiberplast insulators down at Kaiser.
I dressed up like a nurse.
They never had a chance.
I'll bet.
You put them on the machine?
I wish I were there to see that.
Hell no.
There's a beautiful little thing in here called the magic.
And it ain't ever been wrong.
You develop it, you got a brilliant career ahead of you.
I'm working on it.
What scoos I got you doing tonight?
A.M.
at Runciter's.
Animal murder.
Oh, those skin jobs got no respect for anything that truly lives and breathes.
And that god damn Eldon Tyrell ought to be zipped into a body bag and flushed into deep space.
Yeah.
Get rid of him, we'd be out of a job.
Oh.
I think we're all overdue for a little off-world paid vacation.
So true.
You can stop staring at my ass now.
You got eyes in the back of your head?
All you gotta do is ask, Slim.
Tau!
She knows she's hot.
Animal sales was a profitable and prestigious business, since most real animals have died out after a terrible war.
Oh my gosh, I remember this so much.
There were plenty of electric ones, though, powered by rechargeable batteries.
Here we start pointing and clicking, everybody!
No self-respective human would own one of those frauds.
Okay, hold on.
Once...
Oh gosh, this...
It's...
The sensitivity is still pretty bad.
Hopefully that doesn't screw me up during the shooting sequences.
But, um, one thing I am gonna do is I think I'm going to scoot you guys over.
I'm gonna scoot it over a little bit.
Give me one second.
Just like that.
That should be good.
So you guys can see better.
And I'm gonna move our notifications down here.
Thank you guys!
You've been scooted.
Perfect!
The music is so good, right?
All right.
Let's start pointing and clicking!
Oh, I see something here.
Find something?
A piece of chrome.
From a car?
No, I think it's horse chrome.
Bag it and tag it.
What else?
Oh, oh, it turns a different color, I see.
Canvas the area.
Maybe somebody had his eyes open.
I'm on it.
What do you know?
About 30 counts of animal murder and one of aggravated assault.
30?!
The shop's been thrashed.
You ought to see this tiger cup they got here.
No!
It's a goddamn tragedy.
Oh, no!
How's old man Runceter holding up?
I'm sorry, wait.
This isn't a pet store now.
You'd feel the same way if they were your animals.
How many perps?
At least two.
Bloody footprints all over the scene.
Must be a delightful sight.
No, tiger tiger.
Scratches and paint flecks, and I knew what they meant.
Unless the city had bought a jet black fire truck, somebody had a big fat traffic ticket coming.
Oh, and then this is to go back into our car, right?
I'm testing it out.
We're not leaving.
Maybe we are leaving.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I remember this so...
How do I get it out of the car?
I guess I just click it.
Okay, here we go.
This is a pet store, but we're selling tigers?
Interesting.
Anybody else got something to say?
Canvass the area.
Maybe somebody had his eyes open.
Animal strip club.
Yeah, a little bit.
Let's go inside.
I already checked for a crowbar, some kind of tool.
No luck, but it looks like we've got some latency.
Make sure the lab boys run them through the mainframe.
Human and rep.
Oh, I pressed the...
Okay, I thought I was going inside.
Judging from the distance between the prints, I was looking for two very big men.
One dragged his right foot...
Look at...
See, see, see!
You can see the...
The shadows?
That's exactly what I was talking about.
...graceful even.
Quite a pair.
See these shadows?
Oh my gosh.
This is everything in my memory.
Security camera.
It'd be a banner day if it recorded anything before it was shot out.
Well, that's what Blade Runner was too.
Oh my gosh.
Look at all the blood.
Oh, even the monkey!
Oh.
Look, I think these are dead animals on the ground.
No!
Wait, I can touch myself.
Ah!
Activated the key of database.
Office door force.
Limping footprints.
Graceful footprints.
Oh, whoa.
What the heck is this?
Oh gosh.
We access...
I'm ruined.
Totally ruined.
We access the pause menu.
McCoy, LPD.
I'm absolutely certain Lucy Devlin was involved in this heinous act.
She's the young girl who works for me.
What did I say?
She's responsible for all this mayhem?
No, of course not.
It was two men acting in concert with her, obviously.
Obviously.
What they look like?
Big and scary and absolutely malevolent.
My precious one.
She was my baby.
Oh.
Um, I didn't mean to say it like that.
Wait, what else can I grab here?
You guys know what I meant.
My precious one.
She was my baby.
Do you want to talk about your precious...
Oh.
Lucy.
Tell me about this Lucy.
Yeah.
There's not a lot I can tell you.
She's only worked for me for a short while.
Is she a replicant?
She's about 14 years old with pink hair.
A very attractive young thing.
She's 14!
How'd you find her?
She came to me with a reference from Ogilvy's in the northwest zone.
What were you asking her to do, mister?
And she's a very reputable home salesman.
Uh-oh.
You treat her well?
Also, her hair is purple!
This guy is such a liar!
She got a desk for some place where she worked.
She used to eat over there.
What's the motives here, mister?
Can you think of anything they might have been after?
First, I thought they wanted money, but I don't keep any in the shop.
Then I thought they wanted to steal my animals, but they started executing them.
Could they have been replicants?
Who else would be capable of such barbaric acts?
All my animals.
Yeah, what's the point of murdering a bunch of animals?
Let's go look at her desk.
I think he had one more prompt we can ask, but...
Oh my gosh, we're the slowest walker ever.
Oh, they're monkeys!
I thought they were...
I thought it was a lizard from far away.
Well, isn't that cute?
Monkey!
What's that?
A candy bar.
Oh, yummy.
Oh, yuck.
I don't think he and I are gonna get along.
Howie Lee's in Chinatown.
I'd eaten there myself.
We got a cage on the ground, we got a dog.
I love old games because everything you need to click on is highlighted.
You just... you barely have to think.
A toy dog.
Okay, it looks like we can go back there, but maybe not yet.
Monkey!
Monkeys.
The vibes are unmatched, right?
So good.
All right, we had one more thing to ask him.
Like the reference.
You ever do any business with the Replicant Manufacturers, Tyrell Corporation?
I resent that accusation.
The way he's moving.
Officer, last May I personally sold Governor Kolvig an exquisite Bertrand coat.
I have been a guest at his house on three separate occasions.
Do I look like I need to carry artificial product?
All my animals.
Okay.
Chill.
Hold on, I have something else to ask.
See if you can dig up that reference for Mogulby's.
Yes, it's somewhere here.
Just a moment.
Peak Noir aesthetic.
Only rivaled by the OG Blade Runner in Dark City.
Oh, he's going.
He's getting it.
Nice.
Our reference.
Oh, did he...
Oh, he's still getting it.
I can't control anything.
My cursor is gone.
Why is he walking in circles?
Here you are.
Oh, thank you.
He's one of those types that can cannot turn, you know, he can only turn left.
Okay.
I'm ruined.
Totally ruined.
Is that everything?
Stick around.
I may not be finished with you.
I think that's everything that I can see.
Right?
It's so creepy.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
The sound of the water?
I'm ruined.
Totally ruined.
The sound of the water also triggered like a nostalgia.
I think there's like a sewer part we also go through.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
I'm going to beat it.
I'm going to be insufferable this whole, this whole play through.
Alex, happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
I'm ruined.
Totally ruined.
Okay.
We get it.
You don't have to keep telling us.
Oh, you can run if you double click it.
Nice.
It didn't add up.
Animal murders, the lack of any theft, the small animals alone, were worth a good chunk of change on the street.
Totally ruined.
It seemed more like an act of vengeance.
Find anything else out here?
Zilcho, real actions inside.
Really cute.
Abstract art all over the walls and ceiling.
I never did appreciate art.
What?
I mean...
Okay.
All right.
What do I...
Okay, let's see.
Canvas the area.
Maybe somebody had his eyes open.
No.
I'm on it.
Why does it say live?
It really does look like a strip club, doesn't it?
But they're...
But they're animals.
The whole...
The inside too even looked like it.
Make the last name ruined.
First name totally.
I think animal man might be ruined.
I don't know.
I think he needs to say it a couple more times to believe it.
I wonder now...
Do we go somewhere?
There was like the Chinatown he talked about.
I guess we go there.
Aha!
Pre-rendered scenes in this game were made with lightweight 3D, which was favorite in the 90s in TV...
Movies and games for realistic lighting.
It's having a renaissance.
Oh, cool.
All right, to Chinatown!
Wow!
This game looks so good.
And the...
Real sushi was a luxury reserved only for the elite, since most sea life had become radioactive after the Third Terran War.
Sushi is not Chinese.
The rest of us had to eat musu, soya mixed with off-world lichen.
Um, the...
The walking, when he's walking, it sounds like, um...
What's it called?
It sounds like the Barbie movies.
It's very, like, clicky-clacky.
McCoy, LPD.
Hey!
Oh, he left.
I'm talking to you here!
Can I talk to you?
McCoy, LPD.
Hey!
Stop!
Stop it!
This is officer work.
Ray McCoy, Rep Detect.
Hey!
Okay, I guess, uh...
Let's go talk to the chef.
Beautiful night, isn't it?
When business driving, night always beautiful.
Hey, big guy.
Easy!
No time for talk!
Okay!
McCoy, Itazura suruna.
You want something, you talk to me.
Sorry, Howie.
Got to mix more out back.
Speaks Japanese.
Itazura suruna.
Uh, wait, wasn't there...
Okay, well, this guy looks pretty suspicious with his big old red coat.
McCoy, LPD.
I want to ask you a couple of questions.
Sorry, my man.
I just don't got the time.
Gordos, don't...
He doesn't have the ta...
Wait, really?
Wait, the guy actually left.
Wait, I can go inside.
I'm breaking and entering.
Um...
Wow, nice green goop he got there.
Isn't this supposed to be...
It's literally Chinatown, speaks Japanese.
Okay.
Let's go talk to him.
Hello.
Howie says you're a master chef.
You not come back here.
Air bad.
This will only take a minute.
I'm looking for a girl, about 14 years old, with pink hair.
You seen her?
I don't know her.
Uh-oh.
We're in pursuit?
Oh my god.
Wait, uh...
Okay.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, I'm actually gonna shoot!
Go, go, go!
Oh my god.
Go!
Uh, I don't think that's our guy.
Oh my gosh, I could just kill a guy, if I wanted.
Holy cow.
I'm scared.
What if he shoots me?
I don't see him.
I'm Ronan?
Wait, why am I shooting all of a sudden?
All in a day...
Oh, oh my gosh.
I told you, this game is scary, no?
Locked.
Is that our guy?
Because he spilled the soup.
Maybe I was supposed to shoot that guy.
Well, uh...
Too late now.
Is there anything?
This way.
Maybe.
Was that our guy?
That wasn't our guy, though!
Ah.
Oh.
Oh, did I break the game?
Ah.
Yeah, didn't...
He wasn't wearing his little...
His little...
Tank top.
I'm not just gonna shoot a guy.
Ha.
Maybe we want a taste of the soup.
BabyCorn, thank you so much for the gift.
And thank you.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Huh.
No.
I need to get inside your home, please!
Just...
Just barge on in your LAPD!
Um...
Scary?
Blacked.
Start...
Wait, can we shoot the lock?
I don't think we can...
Oh, no, because it didn't...
Okay, well, I guess we leave.
We lost our guy!
Dang!
Am I just gonna run around with my gun out?
That's kind of scary.
He...
He pulled a fast one on me!
He spilled the soup!
God, I love the way people hold their guy's white arm in the air, randomly waving it around.
Right?
Well, this is very futuristic, and, uh...
Honestly, I think we did the people a favor.
They shouldn't be eating the sludge.
Oh my god!
I still have my gun out!
I can just shoot anybody I want!
Wait, how am I supposed to talk to anybody?
Wait!
Right click?
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Wait, if I left click...
If I right click again...
Oh!
I see!
Hey, your guy just, um, runs it across...
It's from your place, isn't it?
Could be.
Chopstick come from Yoshi's restaurant supply.
Yoshi restaurant supply, you say?
How long has that chef worked for you?
Zubin?
Just a month!
Superior chef makes all kinds of new suits.
New suits?
Talk with your gun.
What's real fresh tonight?
Special ship in the portal, just the right.
Whoa!
I'd fix you right up, no one else.
Thank you!
Clean as a whistle.
Oh!
You're Prince, Howie.
Aww!
Really?
You're gonna make me?
Oh my gosh, he just gave it to us.
See you later, Howie.
Wait, no!
Okay.
See you, Howie.
You're...
Howie, you have a big mess to clean up back there.
But I thought fish poison.
I think they said that it was like some things were...
Guys, I might be stupid with this game.
I'm not gonna lie.
Hold on, let's go back to the animal place.
There's a lady staring at us.
Have you guys ever seen that?
I think it was in Dubai.
There's like this super big building.
And then they had...
I think it was Rihanna on it.
But her face was just completely stretched.
At any time I see those types of buildings, I just think of that.
Her face was like...
She's like, hi, I'm Rihanna.
And her face is like crazy looking.
Well, now we can shoot.
That's so exciting, no?
Oh, this place is so creepy with nobody here.
Oh my gosh.
I don't think we have anything else to do here.
It's so creepy!
Okay, let's leave.
See, it feels haunted.
It's a fire hydrant.
If that place is lo...
Okay, let's...
When in doubt, go to the police station.
They'll tell us what to do.
Right?
It's possible you can do more with the door when you don't have the gun out.
Maybe...
I could try that.
Review my evidence?
What do I do?
I...
Oh yeah, click on myself.
Wow!
Okay.
About 30 counts of animal murder and one of aggravated assault.
I already checked for a crowbar, some kind of tool.
Oh yeah, the...
No luck, but it looks like we've got some lateness.
Lucy.
Oh!
Okay, can I look at it?
Nope.
Okay.
Door forced, graceful footprints.
Well, we already know what the guy looked like.
Whereabouts?
Oh.
Wow.
This game is way more...
My dad did all the things then.
So excited about 2019!
We will have flying cars that can speak Japanese.
They can hold a gun!
Clues.
Audio recording.
Wait, we have...
Oh.
Audio recording.
We got the chopstick wrapper...
Candy, that's right.
Oh, the toy dog.
I don't...
Is that a clue?
This thing?
Why is this a clue?
It's brown cow candy.
Howie Lee's in Chinatown.
I'd eaten there myself.
Yeah.
Gosh, it's so loud, that sound effect.
Okay.
Yeah, 2019 will be our year, guys.
Roof.
Mainframe and shooting rings.
She scared me.
Wait!
Mainframe and shooting rings.
I kind of want to try the shooting rings.
Violent street crime in the city rose again last year by a whopping 26 percent, according to the latest figures from the Department of Justice.
Governor Kulvig attributed the change to the dramatic increase in the number of specials.
28.
Oh wait, we're McCoy.
Oh, we haven't tried at all.
Registered as city residents and promised a tough new set of standards for the city immigration bureau by next month.
Old copies of case files, notices, and memos.
The usual station junk.
This place is a dump.
Where is the shooting range?
Oh wait, it probably is this side, huh?
Well, if it ain't Ray McCoy, Bryant finally letting you play with the big boys.
My clearance come through?
You bet.
You bring your piece?
Don't leave home without it.
What's the piece?
Steel's been running the maze every other day for two weeks.
And the targets are getting a little roughed up.
Yeah, Deckard kind of sucks.
I thought Guzer was going to reposition some new ones.
He got only 10 points.
I ain't seen him in a better than a month.
We're going to sweep him.
And everybody else.
Poor guy.
I bet he gets all tuckered out from pushing those papers around.
Oh.
And don't sell him short, McCoy.
Slang for gun.
Guzer could be one tough hombre.
I remember when we worked vice together.
He poured acetone on two pimps that gave us some lip and lit a match.
I'll tell you, it looked like the goddamn 4th of July out there.
Peachy.
That guy.
He'll just set you on fire.
Laughs.
Laughs in red.
What is this?
What is that?
What in the umineko is this?
Okay.
Um, well, hold on.
I want to go to the shooting range.
This is the shooting range, right?
What is this?
Hey.
Use the esper for the first time.
Esper late than never.
What is this?
Nothing is being explained to me.
I can't even click anything.
Nothing comes up.
Am I using it?
I'm clearly not using it correctly.
Uploading personal clue database.
Very 90s.
Downloading mainframe clue database.
I think we're doing it.
Okay.
Clue database transfer complete.
All right.
Cool.
Bicep.
Okay.
Where's the shooting range?
Okay, Esper room.
Someone's cigarette.
Lucky strikes.
Crystal's brand.
I knew she was spending a lot of time in the training maze these days.
Even though she'd already gotten close to a perfect score.
Where...
Where is it?
Am I stupid?
It's not this door.
Maybe it is...
Maybe it's through here.
Hello, I would like to try...
You keeping busy, pal?
Pale.
Nah, the place has been pretty quiet the last couple of days.
2019 is confusing.
Where's the shooting range, please, sir?
Oh, wait.
Hit the lock, Jack.
I guess there ain't no harm in it.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh!
This area!
I remember this so much.
Okay.
Wait, how do I do that?
I'm scared.
Oh
my gosh, I got shot at!
That seems...
I can't tell.
That looked like a lady.
Ow!
Wow!
Oh, oops.
I shot a lady.
Did I get it?
Did I?
Oh, I see.
I have to wait to see if they have a gun or not.
Ouch!
I'm shooting him!
Shoot him!
Okay, this is going to go really well for us now, isn't it?
Oh, yeah.
I'm a killing machine.
Oh, shoot!
How did I...
I couldn't see if she had a gun or not.
Yeah.
Completed sequence.
Proceed to next station.
Did I win?
Oh, where's the next station?
Where?
This way?
I won again.
Nope.
We're still going.
Got my gun out.
Holy sh...
Ow!
Holy cow!
Oh, there's people everywhere!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ow!
I shot you!
No, I didn't.
Oh, that's a baby.
Oh my gosh.
We're killing machines.
We're killing machines!
I'm going to beat Deckard and his...
and everything.
That's a baby.
Baby with a gun.
Oh my gosh, I definitely clicked.
But it didn't register it!
Oh my gosh.
No, I'm running!
Why?
Stop, stop running!
Stop running.
Why are you running?
Is that guy...
Completed sequence.
Proceed to next station.
The baby with a gun.
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
I'm ready.
Freddy.
I'm not ready.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't know if I'm...
Oh, that was a baby.
Sorry.
I can't tell.
That's a gun.
The baby with a gun.
Oh, I got him.
Completed sequence.
Holy cow.
Proceed to next station.
I'm killing babies!
Your personality.
Definitely erratic.
Where's the next station, ma'am?
Do I go back?
Completed sequence.
No.
Proceed to next station.
Next station.
I wonder what our score is.
Probably max.
Um.
Where do I go from here?
Completed sequence.
Proceed to next station.
I wonder what our score is.
I found it.
Run.
That's a baby.
Oh my god.
I got you.
Kill.
That's a baby.
Ew.
Guys, what do you think my score is?
What do you think my score is?
That's a baby.
Completed all sequences.
Damn, that was a good run.
At least.
Oh.
Proceed to exit.
Completed sequence.
Proceed to next station.
Not bad.
Wrong one.
I think we got the top score.
Completed all sequences.
Proceed to exit.
Why is it so wet in here?
Yippee!
Get the first place!
No way!
Old copies of case files, notices, and mail.
Oh, we just barely did it.
We just barely beat Steely.
I almost got 69 for real.
Nice.
I'm a shooting queen.
Nah, take that everybody else on the team.
We're so ready for...
Wait, where'd my...
Okay, I was like, where'd my cursor go?
Oh, oh, right.
We were playing the game.
Round floor.
Mainframe and shooting.
Laboratory.
Roof.
I like the way she says roof.
Loved old point and clicks.
The style reminds me of the longest journey game.
I don't know that one.
Epic shooting.
First try.
Let's go, baby.
I'm Officer Wisp.
We think you'd fit right in.
Thank you!
I only shoot babies sometimes.
Let's try going back to Chinatown.
And seeing maybe if we can do something.
If my gun isn't out.
Off world.
All right.
Oh, look.
Wait, there's somebody here.
Was that guy here before?
Oh, I can't talk to them.
Nope.
What have you been doing this whole time, my guy?
I think I should have shot that guy.
Dang it!
I have one chance to...
Wait, I can search in here.
I found a clue!
What was that?
I found...
Nothing even remotely interesting, but hell.
If I was going to root through trash, my expectations weren't too high.
I got something.
I don't know what it is.
Huh.
A license plate?
It came and went so quickly.
Totally uninteresting.
Okay, then why'd you have me click on it?
Okay, my bad.
Totally uninteresting.
What about this?
It's totally uninteresting, too.
Yuck.
Yuck!
Like, totally uninteresting.
Like...
The way he goes up the stairs is so funny.
I don't see anything that click.
Locked.
I proposed to my girlfriend on Friday.
She said, yes!
You are!
Oh my gosh!
Congratulations!
Wait.
It would mean the world to her if you said hi to my wife, Theodora!
Hello, Theodora!
Congratulations!
On our marriage.
Our marriage.
Our proposal.
Okay, well we just got that thing.
We got the license plate.
Maybe we go run it, you know?
Maybe we go back to the...
We go back to the police station and we run the numbers.
Maybe.
I thought it was always that if someone is like, I'm getting married.
Here's my wife.
I thought it was always obvious that it was our wife.
I thought that was just, you know, common sense.
Boss, you shot a baby.
Amazing.
That right there is why you're the best, boss.
Okay.
Let's go run some numbers.
Why am I walking so slow?
Okay.
You didn't know anything about this?
See you later, Howie.
Bye, Howie.
Excuse me, pal.
Come here.
Excuse me.
You got anything that's a match for these?
McCoy, LPD.
Nobody respects you.
Why?
I wonder what the enhanced version looks like.
I feel like this looks just totally fine, no?
Like, this looks great.
Oh, he did a little 360.
Does that mean Firefly is your wife too?
Stop coping, ducky.
Is running with blades OSHA compliant?
Yeah.
Okay.
Where do we go to run a plate?
Laboratory.
The laboratory.
Lockup.
Lockup?
Who's in there?
Ground floor.
Mainframe and shooting range.
What does mainframe mean?
Laboratory.
Let's try the laboratory.
Whoa, there's so many wanted posters.
Hello?
Got anything new for me, Dino?
I was wondering when you'd show your mug around here, McCoy.
Hello.
We got the animal corpses from Runciter's, but there wasn't a whole lot to work with.
Bone marrow?
About 50% were real, the rest were fakes.
So, Runciter was ripping his customers off.
Wow, what a surprise.
State of the art fakes.
Miles beyond the crap you see on Anemoid Row.
The kind that comes from legit manufacturers?
They're the ones that usually produce the quality.
What about the wounds?
Most of them were shot point blank, but we're looking at some others.
Sloppy cuts with a knife.
Like the perp was really pissed off at something.
Butcher knife?
Could be, but who cuts meat anymore?
Nice bunch of reps I'm tailin'.
Hope you're not pulling a meat cleaver out of my back next week.
Stay hydrated, thank you, I have been.
Hmm...
Nasty!
Anything else?
That black paint you found on the fire hydrant?
It's from a ground car.
You sure?
The angle of impact was almost head on.
And there ain't too many spinner drivers klutzy enough to smack a street level hydrant in VTOL mode.
I heard your wife got her license back.
Heh, you're a real funny guy, McCoy.
What?
Are we still looking for the animal killer?
Y-yes?
Anything else?
Oh, yeah.
That piece of chrome you found outside of Runcidas is from a 1995 Pontiac.
Nice set of wheels.
It's okay, not what I call a classic.
Well, it's classic now.
Retro.
Anything else?
Zip man, try me later.
Okay, thank you.
Honestly, I don't know what I'm doing in this game.
But I'm having fun.
I have no idea what's going on.
Mainframe and shooting range.
Maybe we try here with the...
Shut up.
Maybe the license plate is working now.
Downloading mainframe clue data...
Clue database transfer complete.
Okay.
This thing sucks.
It's broken!
Esper machine!
Just give it a good couple of whacks.
I don't understand.
Okay.
We just have to be smart, I guess.
Um...
Maybe he knows.
You keeping busy, pal?
Nah, the place has been pretty quiet the last couple of days.
Okay.
We missed the camera discs.
Hm?
We missed something.
Where at?
I think this game is, not gonna lie, pretty easy to miss things at.
You needed the security footage...
See, I tried to!
Wait, really?
But I tried to get...
I...
I hovered over it, but nothing happened.
Okay, let's go again.
Consult the manual.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
This is actually, like, the era of gaming where...
Oh, no!
Not Chinatown!
I'm stupid.
But this is the era of gaming where they were like, Yeah, people read the manual and it actually was the tutorial for the game.
I
didn't mean to come back here.
I'm obsessed with the sushi.
I'm obsessed with the... with Chinatown sushi.
Call Campbell.
That sushi.
Okay.
Well, maybe...
Because no one's here, maybe we can go into that back room also.
Let's get some security footage, baby!
I clicked on it before, no?
Security camera.
It'd be a banner day if it recorded anything before it was shot out.
Right?
So, grab it.
I don't like this area, it spooks me.
See, all I got is monkey.
There's nothing else in here.
Wait, how am I supposed to get it?
Was there somewhere else that I didn't click on?
There's nothing... nowhere to go on the sides.
Cell type!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
What do you mean, bother me?
You're never... it's never a bother.
Thank you, lad.
Thank you for the super tie.
Happy belated birthday!
Try the desk?
Yeah, I tried.
Nothing there.
Security camera.
It'd be a banner day if it recorded anything before it was shot out.
I'm struggling here.
That's why I was like, I thought I...
Wait, wait.
Wait, I saw blue?
Oh.
Because of this area.
Yeah, there's no way to get past the curtain.
Now we have to ask the guy for the footage.
But where is he?
Is he being locked up?
Is he held downtown?
Ask the guy for the footage.
Shoot the camera?
Ha ha ha ha.
You need...
Run sitter here for this.
But he's not here.
Uh oh.
You can't get softlocked in this game.
I clicked on that though!
I did!
I clicked on the security camera before I talked to him.
Maybe we go home and take a nap.
Did you?
I did.
I clicked it.
Let's go home and take a nap.
Maybe our virtual girlfriends then.
Did they arrest him for his animals dying?
What if they arrested him because some of his animals were fake?
That could be the case.
Right?
How do I get inside my home?
Home?
Oh.
You can misplot elements but you can't get into unwinnables.
Oh!
There's a guy walking.
Very slowly but I can't do anything.
Rumor has it you've been earning your stripes, McCoy.
I just shot that guy!
Oh my god!
Working on it.
Keep it up.
You just might have a future in this business.
Did you see that?
I understand it's got a hell of a retirement plan.
You'll VK the mark before retirement?
You're not gonna address it?
Didn't have to.
That's why they call it the magic.
I'm starting to understand.
If you ever retire a human, your career is over.
Remember that.
What?
I checked with UN Air.
Looks your rep swung that Moonbust massacre last month.
I was supposed to shoot him though, right?
He was ambushing me at my own home!
You disappeared into thin air.
Brian thinks it crashed out in the kipple.
How many reps are we talking about?
Enough.
They're Nexus Sixes.
So don't take too much slap.
I should pay attention.
Oh my gosh.
What?
Who...
What just happened?
Okay.
Alright.
Yuck.
Atom Man, you just killed!
This game is ridiculous!
What?
He was coming at me!
Was I supposed to let it happen?
I don't know!
That's me.
Unloads your entire gun on one man.
I see her in your stripes.
The future of 2019 is often folks running...
I lived with the best gal I'd ever seen.
She was two now and full of life and love.
She'd cost me about a year's salary, but she was worth it.
Oh, your dog!
It was good to have someone warm nearby after completing a dirty job.
And the retirement swag from this case would go toward getting her a partner.
Swag.
Wait.
Your dog?
Maggie, come here, girl.
Oh, Maggie!
So cute!
What about our robot girlfriend?
Where is she at?
She's on here on the telly?
Oh, it's the aspirin machine!
Get this shit out of here!
I hate this thing!
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
Oh, yeah!
Can we pet the dog?
Maggie, come here, girl.
Pet the dog.
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
Here you go, baby!
Wow, this place is so...
Wow.
Zubin was the first Nexus 6 I'd come up against.
There was something in his eyes.
An almost primordial desire to live.
Most of the threes, fours, and fives I'd seen would just give up.
That was the guy we shot.
But these sixes, they were a whole other breed.
You saw the look in his eye?
I don't know, you said yuck!
You looked at his body and you said yuck!
There was like a look in his eye to live.
As you unloaded your gun on him?
Yeah, we didn't report it or anything!
Primordial and yucky.
I was gonna say, is this the bathroom?
I thought we would customize our appearance a little bit.
Hey, you can use the toilet in this game.
Can we sleep?
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
Oh!
It's been one of those days.
Reach Act 2!
Are we dreaming?
What is happening?
What?
Oh my god, we're going into the anti-gravity room.
Oh no.
It's about a third of what we got here on Terra.
Why are you letting the pets just float in space?
How about turning that dial, okay?
When I say...
Oh!
Please...
Can you control your rat?
I'll have you know that Ricky's a purebred chihuahua.
Chihuahua?
Things going good at Tyrell Corporation?
Boring, boring.
Old man Tyrell's been on a Vagma kick lately.
He never shuts up.
I'm nervous about Maggie in this game, not gonna lie.
Me too.
Dang, this guy is nosy.
Chihuahua.
This guy, I don't think he's wearing pants.
I hope he's wearing pants.
Oh!
She's this game's autogon.
Tell me something I don't know.
The organ designers.
Miraji, Hannibal Chu, Luther and Lance.
They're closer to him than I am.
Where?
What a name.
DNA Row.
Hannibal Chu human.
They're all working down on DNA Row.
No, no, no.
You're one miserable package man.
No.
No, please don't.
Oh, right in the...
Whoa!
That was a weird dream.
Pick up.
Hope you aren't camped out there with a bottle of tequila.
Very funny.
Whatever that is.
Early bird slays the worm, McCoy.
Don't worry.
I'm up, Lieutenant.
What's the buzz?
She-huah-huah.
One of Tyrell's employees got his fat face splattered all over the marble interior of the Tyrell building.
Inside?
That's right.
But we also got a sweet little break at it.
Tyrell's surveillance system recorded the whole shebang.
She-bang.
Beautiful.
How many perps?
Just one.
I don't know if it's related to the Run Center deal or not.
Tyrell's security will have a disc for you when you get there.
Okay.
You'll be good, killer.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
Wait, no, no.
Don't go back to sleep.
Wake up!
No!
Oh, shoot.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
Alright.
Very good.
Maggie!
Maggie, come here, girl.
Maggie is so cute.
I worry for Maggie, too.
Nothing better happen to Maggie.
Maggie.
Maggie's our little baby.
Also, Maggie barks a lot, actually.
This is why I can't have dogs.
Do androids dream of electric freaks?
Yeah.
Wow, there really isn't anything in our house to interact with.
That kind of sucks.
What if I go to the ground floor?
I'm just curious.
Ground floor.
Because obviously our car was on the roof.
So...
Whoa.
Ew.
We're just awkwardly standing here.
Whoa.
I like the...
This whole game looks so cool.
Oh, wait.
We can get to the police station from here?
I can see my house from here.
So...
2019.
Look at him go.
Hi,
here we are.
Can I talk to anybody?
Oh, that's the elevator, I guess.
What's this?
Click.
What do you know?
What do you care?
Who are you?
You're just a person.
You're the only one I can talk to.
What's her name?
Hey, pal.
Hey, talk to me.
Hey.
You killed anyone yet?
Oh, it's Gaff.
Yeah, I did actually.
I did kill a person.
What do you know?
Zero that would interest you, detective.
Okay, thanks, Officer Grifford.
Wait, what's over here?
I'm just exploring a little bit.
I know we gotta go to the Tyrell building.
I'm just taking a look around.
Oh, it's this guy!
Hey, I killed a guy.
Money?
Can the department float me some chin yen?
This investigation's getting expensive.
Look, this ain't on the department tab, okay?
This is a personal loan.
Oh.
Thanks, Lieutenant.
This goddamn city don't know how to manage funds.
They haven't been flushed for years.
Huh?
I thought we were under budget.
Trust me, ain't nobody getting rich unless they're sneaking some on the side.
Hell, I can barely pay for the fuel for my car.
Ever hear of public transportation?
Aw.
Get out of here before I throw my desk at you.
Bryant, go on permanent leave and you get full use of the office, Lieutenant?
You'd be amazed at how accommodating a man can be after his hemorrhoids get lanced.
You've really been surprising the troops around here, kid.
I know, I'm doing a good job.
Gaff says you work their retirement like a champ.
Just doing the job.
Yeah, well, don't get too cocky.
Those sixes can be damn unpredictable.
Not the hemorrhoids.
That, I know.
But I'm proud of you, McCoy.
Why don't you take the rest of the day off?
Thanks.
Wait, no.
Famous is writing the advance to your account as we speak.
What?
How much?
Couple hundred chin-yen.
Enough to buy a sandwich or two.
We gotta hold back the rest until the lab does the autopsy.
Wait, but I'm supposed to go like...
Paperwork, you know.
Shouldn't take more than a couple of days.
So, the check's in the mail.
Hey, don't worry.
The boys upstairs wanna keep our best and brightest happy.
Any idea what you wanna spend it on?
Yeah, we just woke up, but it's perpetually night here.
And I was thinking...
Maybe a companion for my animal at home.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Forget that.
Buy yourself something.
Something nice.
Yeah, a companion would be nice.
Once you start carving up that juicy bacon, kid, the taste never goes away.
The great things in life, believe me, you'll just be wanting more and more.
Bacon.
Okay.
Well, I'm gonna take the rest of the day off then.
What the heck?
Um, okay.
We have to go to our car, so we can't stay here.
Forget what.
That dog is everything to McCoy.
Yeah!
Look at him running.
Um, how do I get home?
This way?
Wait, so is this the ground floor?
Where are we?
This place is confusing.
We can't go to the right.
So that just leads to...
This looks like something will come out of...
Your floor number, please.
No, please.
We're going to the roof.
Roof.
It's the dog button.
Okay, we're... Oh, somebody cleaned up that guy!
Nice going.
Cleanup crew.
XOF out here.
Okay.
Not yet.
Oh, wow, there's the title.
Well, before we do that, we're going to go back to Run-Sitters.
And see if that guy's there.
If we can somehow get the security.
If not, then we go to Tyrell.
We just call it a loss, I guess.
I feel like there's got to be something, though, that we missed.
Or like...
I feel like I remember getting it when my dad played.
And us...
Locked.
Locked?!
What do you mean?!
Okay.
Skull Face is covering for McCoy.
There we go.
Yuck.
Door locked?
What is awful?
Whoa!
L.A.'s on fire!
Tyrell pyramids.
McCoy, LPD.
Hello.
Just a minute.
Where do I go?
Grab test on the east wing.
66th floor.
Here's the footage from the security cameras.
Thank you!
You get a pretty good look at the man's face.
All right!
How'd he get past you guys?
He pretended to be a delivery man.
Oh, my gosh.
Uber Eats.
The dealer ordered in a lot, so it didn't seem unusual.
I may have more questions for you later on.
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Actually, right now.
One more thing.
I told you everything I know, detective.
Just kidding.
I gotta work.
These monitors don't watch themselves.
Yeah.
It's a tough gig.
I hear like 15 conversations going...
Whoa!
What the hell?
Wait, this...
Oh, this is the room.
Holy cow.
This is freaky.
Jesus.
Oh!
Why'd they strip his body?
Why'd they make him naked?
I've seen worse, but not by much.
Oh, that's a terrible sound.
Whatever that is.
You could strain him through a sieve.
Oh, it's a blanket?
Oh, maybe a rye.
Oh, I hate that sound.
Whatever that is.
What are you doing?
The book is here.
Stop.
A takeout box from Kingston Kitchens.
Kingston Kitchens.
Okay, that sounds like a new place we can go.
I'd seen more dead animals than live ones in the last 24 hours.
And now it was dogs.
Three of them.
I thought about Maggie and nearly threw up.
Sorry, the delivery.
This sucks.
Okay.
King voice acting right there.
No, no, no.
This thing right here.
I'd seen more dead animals than live ones in the last 24 hours.
And now it was dogs.
Three of them.
I thought about Maggie and nearly threw up.
Thought about Maggie and nearly threw up.
Obviously he'd been killed with an explosive.
And not just because he'd been plastered on the wall with a thousand strokes.
The detonator wire I pulled out of his skull said the whole story.
Oh, nasty.
But I wondered why the killer didn't just shoot him.
Yeah.
He wanted to make a... cause a scene.
Okay, I hate this room.
It sounds... I don't like the sound in it.
So I'm trying to get everything that I can.
Wait, I think that's another dog.
I've seen more dead animals than... and now it was dogs.
I thought about Maggie and nearly threw up.
Okay, I think... okay, there's the three dogs.
What's... what's this right here?
The dog collar has a name on it.
Ricky, maybe?
Ricky!
Um...
I really hate the sound here.
If you spawn anything you think I oughta know about, tell me.
Absolutely.
Thanks, Mr. Photographer.
The sound effect is so funny.
This looks like it should be something, but it's not.
If you spawn anything you think I oughta know about...
Okay.
Alright, let's leave.
Cause it's...
I hate... high-pitched sound.
Oh, anything on the walls.
You're right.
Let's go back in.
This up here?
I think that's the security camera he shot.
Um...
I don't see anything on the walls.
Can I walk around the room at all?
No.
Okay, I think we're...
I think we're done.
Oh my gosh, horrible.
I even turned it down for you guys.
Anything in here?
Oop, what's that?
It was a Tyrell sales brochure for the Nexus series.
The kind of glossy hype that ends up littering the floor at trade shows.
This one was for the new entertainment model.
A comedian designed to entertain the troops off-world.
Fine.
What's this?
The earring was shaped like an insect.
I didn't know much about jewelry, but it looked like junk to me.
Like the cheap crap sold at the stands and shops of Animoid Row.
Or...
It's a clue.
I don't think our...
I don't think our guy in there wore earrings, huh?
Okay.
We...
That's a V-tuber.
Lagging behind again?
Oh!
Guza didn't say anything about me working with a partner.
Oh, in a pig's ass, Slim.
No.
I'm following up on my own.
Oh, damn.
Could be it's linked to this Tyrell debacle.
Her case.
How's yours connected to mine?
I'm still putting the pieces together.
It's all stored in Esper's mainframe.
Ah, yours works?
Did you hear about the Moonbus massacre?
What?
Jeff mentioned it.
Could be our cases are overlapping.
I might keep you posted.
Laughs in Japanese.
Do that.
Wait, wait.
Don't leave yet.
No!
Murder like we could shoot her?
That'd be crazy.
Earring, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You know if anyone lost an earring like this one lately?
Not one of the employees, that's for sure.
The boss enforces a strict dress code around here.
How did Eisenduller's Moomoo fit in?
Yeah, you know, company rules only apply to the lesser mortal.
Not the Moomoo!
You friendly with Eisenduller?
Most of the employees they see coming in morning and night, but old Marcus...
I mean, uh, Dr. Eisenduller.
He almost never left his lab.
He afraid of somebody?
I think it had something to do with the air outside.
And the germs.
The germs!
I once heard him complain about it.
Smart.
What was his job?
Grub test chief engineer.
The lab runs tests to see how a replicant would perform in different planetary gravitational fields.
That kind of thing.
One of the other engineers could tell you more.
Whoa!
Where are the other engineers?
Well, we got that one tape.
We can put it in the Esper.
Oh, wait!
Now we have Anemoid Row because of the earring!
Nice!
Let's go back to the apartment real quick.
Because I want to see if the Esper works.
Oh, wait.
Do I have to upload it first?
Maybe I should go to the police officer.
We'll try.
The
thing that allegedly has at least 88 floors.
There's not a lot of parking spots.
McCoy, 88F.
88.
Thank you.
Good doggy.
Yeah!
Scanning video desk.
It's working!
One enhanceable image found.
Enhance!
Adding enhanceable photographs to Kaya database.
Oh, it's Kaya!
Tyrell Grav Test Lab.
Beep boop beep!
Brrrp boop!
Whoa!
What do I do here?
Ah!
Brrrp boop!
Brrrp!
Germs in 2019?
I hope that's not prophetic.
Uh...
What am I supposed to do here?
Brrrp boop!
Is it gonna tell me anything?
Can I zoom out?
Oh, here we go!
Okay.
We'll zoom in on our guy here.
Brrrp boop!
Check out what gun he's using.
Brrrp brrrp brrrp brrrp!
Brrrp brrrp!
Brrrp brrrp brrrp!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Beep beep!
Maybe I need to enhance more?
Brrrp brrrp brrrp brrrp brrrp brrrp brrrp!
What is this technology?
The earring was shaped like an insect.
I didn't know much about jewelry, but it looked like junk to me.
Like the cheap crap sold at the stands and shops of Anemoid Row.
Give me a hard copy of that.
Oh, so if we hadn't gotten the earring there...
We could have gotten the...
The prompt to go to Anemoid Row here.
That's interesting.
Enhance!
How did it...
Look at the dog!
Enhance!
Oh gosh, we're really zooming in on the dog!
Ricky!
The dog collar has a name on it.
Ricky, maybe?
Give me a hard copy of that.
Oh, and if you missed the collar too!
It's kind of interesting.
So it's like everything that we saw at the scene.
But just in case you missed it.
Was there anything hit with him?
No?
Oh, Ricky, you're so fine, you're so fine.
You're on my mind, Ricky!
Ricky!
Enhance!
Keep enhancing!
Okay, never mind.
I think we've run out of everything.
Zoom in on the junk.
It wasn't...
There was like a pizza box or something we found too.
Oh yeah, see, see, maybe this.
They were like, oh, that...
Nope, that's not it.
Wow, though!
Look at the graphics!
This game is really good looking, huh?
Okay.
I think we got it.
Don't feel paranoid about missing clues.
This game has redundant evidences to mitigate that issue.
Just like the collar thing you caught earlier.
Neat!
Okay, bye, Maggie!
Hold on.
Come here.
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
Oh yeah, baby!
What is this?
Huh.
Your floor number, please.
It is very smart.
Oh no, I didn't have her say it!
Oof.
To Anemoid Row.
Wait, this looks exactly like that earring.
Excuse me, pal.
I have questions to ask you.
Or I'm gonna ask this guy here.
You know who deals in insects down here?
You don't want insects?
They're no good companions.
But fish.
Fish are good.
I don't think fish...
I have every kind of fish for you.
I don't think they're any better of a companion.
Whole fish, dorado, miniature sailfish.
Very friendly.
Miniature sailfish?
No, thanks.
I got a dog at home.
Fish just as good as dog.
No, my dog is real.
Real?
Oh, you must make lots of money.
Let's get back to insects.
Official LPD business.
Ah.
Down at end of Animal Row.
You see big green sign?
My dog is real.
You try there.
Is he really?
Good luck with all, friend.
Hope he stays healthy.
She.
Is she really real?
Or is he deluding himself, you know?
What's in here?
Whoa.
Oh.
Excuse me, pal.
Nobody...
Are we invisible?
Like...
Why doesn't anybody acknowledge us?
I hear monkey.
Give me the monkey.
I don't remember this part at all.
I'll be honest.
I got a couple of questions for you, Captain.
Captain.
First one's on the house.
The rest you pay for.
You want chit-chat, you hire a hooker.
This ain't no social club.
I thought the music was going wah-wah.
Pour me one.
Just one?
One, but one good one.
One good one?
Okay, we have to ask you a question.
Or, we...
Pour me one.
Oh, another one?
One?
Okay.
One, but one good one.
Another good one.
Two of them.
Uh...
I thought we were asking questions.
What?
Pour me one.
Wait.
Just one?
Sir, we're on the job!
One, but one good one.
Stop it!
One, but one good one?
What's a good one?
Can't we have another one?
I guess we're not asking questions.
We're getting drunk.
The beer o'clock!
Oh, yeah, we got the day off, huh?
What is this?
That looks like chicken.
Step up!
Mama, Isabella put you something special.
How drunk can I get?
Put a glow in your cheek.
McCoy, LPD.
Mind if I ask you a couple of questions?
Questions?
They always need answers.
Um, this photo.
This guy worked for you?
Oh.
No, but I wish you do.
He be one fine looking man.
You sure?
Never seen him before?
I'd remembered him for sure.
What else?
Marcus...
Oh.
You send a lot of deliveries over to Marcus Eisenduller at the Tyrell building?
Yeah, didn't it?
Eisenduller.
Oh, Eisenduller.
Yeah, this is the place that it had the...
Yeah.
Let me tell you.
That man could do it.
I can't eat.
I had the take out once.
Send anything over lately?
No sir.
No deliveries to him no more.
Not since last month.
He be way behind on his bill.
Not for a month.
He works for a big company and he's not paying his bill.
That means no more till him pay up.
You may have a little trouble collecting.
He's dead.
Oh, I guess she doesn't care about that.
That stew's looking tasty.
Yeah, let's get some stew.
Picture right up.
Only dirty chinion.
It put a spring in your step month.
The ladies, they be loving you.
The ladies.
Did we get one?
Did we get the stew?
What's over here?
Oh, where are we?
We went to Hawkers.
This is Bullet Bob's runner surplus.
Wait, we're like just...
We're just like chilling outside now.
Wait.
I kinda wanna explore a little.
It's true.
Ladies do love stew.
Is that a .45 blaster under your coat?
Or you're just happy to be here?
You got good eyes.
The turret!
They ought to be.
They're the only organs of mine that survived the Phobos Wars intact.
Ray McCoy, Rep Detect.
Blade Runner, huh?
Oh, he said the thing!
He said the thing!
Blade Runner.
Yeah.
That doesn't look very safe.
How come I never heard of you?
I just got assigned.
Yeah, I'm kinda buddies with Davey Holden.
How's he doing?
Word is he's gonna be okay.
That skin job must have been pretty damn quick getting by Davey like that.
He's the best in the business.
He'll be back in the job soon.
Now I'm the best in the business.
Did you see my high score?
Can we buy a gun?
I wanna buy a big ol' big something.
That guy came ambushed.
It came up on me.
I'm scared.
There was this area too.
Let's see.
Happy 15 months, Vicky.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for 15!
We're back here!
Wait, can we go in now?
Locked.
Dang it, why?
Okay, let's go back in.
And then we go this way.
And we keep walking.
We keep going.
Can we go in here?
No.
This guy just pours this one.
And we don't pay for it.
And we also are getting drunk.
Okay.
Where's the monkey coming from?
One other thing.
If you need to be extra persuasive, have your gun out.
Wait, seriously?
Interesting.
You don't say.
Hey, you.
I'm trying to talk to this guy all the way over there.
It works?
No kidding.
Hey, you.
Might I interest you in a snake, noble one?
A snake?
Not today, thanks.
Oh.
No, no.
Come on.
I'm the noble...
The earring.
This your work?
Ah.
Dragon.
Dragon?
Si.
An asoptera.
Dragonfly.
Late of the American South Swamp Plant.
You sell jewelry with dragonflies?
Item like that.
Very special significance.
Very rare, senor.
Estate item.
And most likely part of large collection.
A person must have plenty of money to obtain a collection.
More than I can afford.
You try Hawker's Circle.
Might want to try for this.
With luck, you may find.
If this is from a collection, I'm also looking for the other pieces.
I make you a deal.
I found out where to get dragonfly jewelry.
Uh-huh.
Then, you buy a piece, right?
For special lady friends.
You come back later.
I'll do that.
Our special lady robot.
You take care.
Chasing the dragon.
Um.
Handsome man like you as lady friend.
Of course.
All my girl cares about is food and lava.
Uh, how romantic.
Maggie!
Don't say Maggie.
What is this girl's name?
Maggie.
Maggie, Maggie.
Ah!
Maggie, senor.
It's perfect.
Is it not?
Wait.
So...
They didn't want to make Ryan Gosling in love with his dog?
Kinda starting to worry about McCoy's feelings.
I guess we'll buy it.
It's kinda ugly.
How about you talking?
Damn!
We have no to act, do we?
You hear anything yet about that dragonfly jewelry?
Like what I showed you before?
Yeah, we bought the thing.
No, senor.
My friend, he's asking for me.
If you come back later, maybe I know something more.
I don't think it's that kind of love, are you sure?
Careful, senor.
Your poison.
Ooh, what are they?
Scorpions.
Scorpions!
See?
Finest quality.
Perhaps you purchased one?
Can I?
I don't think so.
They're beautiful though.
No, I want one, please!
I've never seen one before.
Please!
Oh, that'd be true, senor.
Ah, they're so cute.
Okay, so now we have...
We gotta go back home so we can give our dog this beautiful piece of jewelry.
For Maggie.
So let's go home.
Polo waifu or dog dad?
What kind of Blade Runner are you?
Yeah.
He claims that Maggie's real, but for some reason I'm kind of doubting it.
What about hawkers?
That's where we were!
No?
Hold on, we'll go back.
After we give Mackie her present.
What if we die on the job?
I still can't believe we were just running back home and that guys just came out from nowhere.
I can't believe that happened to us.
I'm not over it.
I have trust issues with this rooftop now.
I mean...
Apartment.
Roof.
McCoy.
88F.
88.
Thank you.
That's what life was like in 2019.
Yeah.
So much has changed in the past six years.
Maggie!
Maggie?
Come here, girl.
I got something for you.
Good doggy.
Can you put it on?
No?
Who's the best dog in the whole world?
He's so cute.
Sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff.
Wait, we can't give it to her.
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
Aw, come on.
What do you mean Maggie isn't real?
She's real to me!
I learned that Uma Musume got Ace Combat Composer in the game.
Ace Combat and also Metal Gear.
Hello, Nan.
Who's the best dog in the whole world?
Sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
That scared me.
We have so many clues.
Look at this.
This is insane.
The dog collar has a name on it.
Ricky, maybe?
Ricky.
Maggie.
Oh, wait, here.
This is the bracelet.
It says Maggie on it.
Interesting.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the thing.
Thank you.
The earring was shaped like an insect.
I didn't know much about jewelry, but it looked like junk to me.
Like the cheap crap sold at the stands and shops of Anemoid Row.
Oh, whoa.
Maggie, you good?
Maggie is definitely a robot.
Your floor number, please.
Back
to hawkers.
Massive hawkers.
A real set of godawkers.
What did she say to ask in there about?
I can't remember.
It's fine, we'll figure it out.
It was like, this is Hawkers, no?
Because we came... Is
he gonna pour us another one?
Oh, wait!
Wow.
She's a dog.
So is my wife, but I sure as hell don't brag about it.
Pour me one.
Just one?
One, but one good one.
Yeah, see, it's Hawkers Barkeep.
Pour me one.
Just one?
One, but one good one.
Why did you say it like that?
Anything over here?
Can't talk to these people, we can't disturb them.
I need to ask you...
Whoa!
That guy looks suspicious.
Are you taking any drugs?
Oh, my God!
Nancy Drew, bro.
Truly.
Such a social butterfly.
Oh, my goodness.
Thanks for your time.
I'm a little lost.
Maybe I go talk to that guy with my gun out.
But I'm scared he's gonna get... I'm gonna get shot at or something.
Hey, mister!
I have a question to ask you.
Oh.
Wait, maybe I can't ask him.
Cause I have my gun out.
Pull me one.
Just one?
One, but one good one.
I missed a screen!
Wait, where?
Are you talking about this one?
There was nothing here, though.
Where was there?
Are you taking any drugs?
McCoy, LPD.
Oh, maybe this person.
Oh, she's just standing there.
Two minutes.
That's how much time I give every stranger that wanders in here off the street.
Okay, good.
Sell a lot of stuff that way?
I don't encourage browsers.
What impresses me are people who know what they want and are not afraid to pay for it.
What's the most expensive thing you got in here?
Yeah.
Value is a relative notion.
What's significant to you might be meaningless to me.
And vice versa.
Everything here is guaranteed.
The finest, most authentic anyone here.
Are these drugs?
What are we getting?
I'm scared.
What do you got for me?
Can I go in?
Oh.
What?
That wasn't two minutes.
Wait, how do I...eh?
Excuse me.
Are you on drugs?
I'm
confused.
Will he come back out?
Excuse me, pal.
Want drugs, please?
Yeah.
Excuse me, I would like to buy a drug.
Can you go in?
I can't do anything.
Oh, he's back!
Let me tell you what I want, and maybe I'll impress you.
Or my paperwork is in order.
Doesn't matter.
I don't read, anyhow.
What's your name?
Iza.
You move a lot of valuable goods through here.
I can't read.
Valuable and exotic.
How exotic?
We're talking exceptionally fine jewelry in the shape of a dragonfly.
Oh.
They were so majestic.
Oh, he knows.
I remember them from my childhood.
Oh, dragonflies.
That was the last time I've seen them.
It's very important that I find out about this.
Can you help me?
If I see something, and you can match whatever my collectors will pay, it's all yours.
Thanks a million.
Thank you.
There you go.
I'm looking for some jewelry in the shape of an insect.
Your two minutes are out.
Damn.
No, they're not.
I'm looking for some jewelry in the shape of an insect.
Part of the two minutes was you walking away.
For a whole minute.
No.
We got scammed.
You walked away for a whole minute, though.
Okay.
So now we are waiting on two people to figure out something about the dragonfly.
Time to pull out the gun.
Wait, will it let me?
Let's try.
I wonder how easy it is to game over in this game.
Excuse me, I have some questions to ask you.
It won't let me talk to people with my gun out.
Are we sure that's how we're more persuasive?
I think you have to sleep.
I think so too.
I think that's how you like progress.
You get through a day and then you sleep and then you have something else happen.
How do you save in this?
That's a great question.
Thought you had the day off.
No, he was just saying that.
He was just saying that to be nice.
But the bullets ask the questions.
Yeah, but we won't get answers unless... unless... we miss.
Your floor number, please.
McCoy, 88F.
88.
Thank you.
Maggie!
Come here, girl.
Hello, Maggie.
Stop barking at me.
Hold on, I'm gonna click escape.
Okay, save game.
Nice.
Okay, cool.
Let's go to sleep.
I wish that were me.
I wish I were sleeping.
Wishing I was fishing.
In my dreams.
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
I love how we can just majestically stare out our window.
This feels like a... like a live wallpaper you could have or something, you know?
Just like the ambiance of... of LA in 2019.
With the music and everything.
This is such a vibe!
Do a flip!
Then...
What do we do now?
Maybe since we slept, they'll have the information.
Your floor number, please.
Oof.
I'm suspicious every time I come up here.
The music is great because Frank Papaki is a god.
They didn't have the rights to the music so they had to replicate the movie soundtrack by ear.
That's insane!
What?
My nose is so itchy today.
Back to Anemoid Row.
Let's see if the information has come through yet.
Please.
Please!
The dragonfly!
You hear anything yet about that dragonfly jewelry?
Like what I showed you before?
No, senor.
My friend, he's asking for me.
If you come back later, maybe I know something more.
Okay, well if she doesn't know, I think probably the other guy won't know.
What do I do from here?
Maybe we go to the...
...animal store.
I don't know.
Try the other guy.
We can try.
If he comes back out.
It's perfect timing.
Speak of the devil.
I'm looking for some jewelry in the shape of an insect.
Your two minutes are up.
No!
Please!
I'm gonna shoot you!
I'm gonna shoot!
This is your warning shot!
I swear I'll do it!
Go to Chinatown?
To Chinatown.
Ask him nicely for two more minutes.
Please, sir.
May I have some more?
Please, please, sir.
I was thinking the pet store, but I think it'll still be locked.
Where's the chef?
Wait, where's the guy who does...
Where's Howie?
Howie?
Is he running...
Is he back here?
Taking a smoke break?
No?
Your two minutes may be up, but the rest of his life is up.
Yeah!
Is he with the American Idol?
Oh, look at this!
This is open now.
Not Howie Mandel.
That guy posted his prolapsed anus online.
Whoa, what's here?
Oh.
Nothing?
It's just a shortcut around?
Oh!
Whoa!
Whoa, we went in a full circle!
Yeah, he did that.
That's like the only thing I know about him.
Yeah, he posted his prolapsed anus on...
I think it was...
It might have been TikTok, and people were like, Howie, what is this?
I think we got over that way too quickly, I'm not gonna lie.
Locked.
First time you were here.
Oh!
Hello!
I have a lot of knowledge about different things.
You'll always learn something new on the...
Mint Phantom channel!
Howie, what is this?
No, it's not Freak Phantom...
How is it I'm the freak and I didn't post my...
My booty hole!
We'll just take your word for that.
It's true!
It's a true story!
Guys, I might need to consult the game facts.
I'm lost.
I'm gonna check this place one last time.
Maybe we'll go back to Tyrell.
Peak Freak.
Locked.
Okay.
I write off my super chat too as educational expenses on my dad.
I think that knowing this, like...
This makes you a freak.
No!
Okay, hold on.
Game facts time.
Lead...
Runner...
Game...
Walkthrough.
Messy up there, isn't it?
Yeah.
Do you know anything else, mister?
How do I get in to see the big boss?
You don't, unless he wants to see you.
Okay, how do I make him want to see me?
Well, you could call his personal assistant...
I ask that every day.
Who is...
Don't know, offhand.
Yeah, I get the picture.
I ask that every day of my afterlife.
I may have more questions for you later on.
Yes, sir.
I want to see big boss.
Anything else in here?
Oh, the photographer's gone.
And the dogs!
But they didn't take the guy.
Disgusting.
Jeez.
Everybody is yucky to you, huh?
One day you'll be like that.
Free corpse.
Oops.
Okay, hold on.
The hide and walk through.
Let's see.
Where am I?
I don't think I'm at there.
Oh, I'm only at Act 2.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Apartment.
Okay.
What am I missing?
It says that Two Minutes Guy is meant to have more dialogue, but doesn't say how.
Hmm...
In Blade Runner's LA is based on historical LA's oil fields.
Those oil fields are still technically in LA.
But hidden under...
Facades to blend them in with the surrounding city.
Ooh.
Kinda like how they'll make...
They'll make...
Electrical poles look like trees.
Animoid Row.
Izzo.
Uh...
Talk to him and he'll pull the camera off the shelf.
What?
How?
Uh...
Ah?
Oh?
He didn't do that.
What?
He told me that my two minutes were up.
He doesn't like me.
It's because of my bad personality.
I'm too erotic.
Is this the one from 97?
Yes.
Oh, I think we gotta go to the police station.
Maybe.
Your two users choice.
Which one was the guzzler?
Here?
I think he was on the...
Ground floor.
We make cell phone towers look like palm trees in California.
In Florida, they're just there.
Yeah.
All that 5G.
Oh, here.
Right?
Got it.
Isn't his name guzzler?
Guzzman?
Tell him that was your twin brother.
So you get two more minutes.
Oh!
Hello?
Guzzy?
Wait.
What's that?
I don't see anything else in here.
Huh?
Oh, his name is Guzza.
What did I do wrong?
Thank you, thank you.
They called me the guzzler in college.
They call me that at the club.
Sorry, I'm reading the walkthrough.
I can't tell.
Bring the weapons order to the shooting range.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I think you need to head back to Tyrell.
I already did that.
What?
Mainframe and shooting range.
Maybe I'd talk to these guys.
That weapon shipment just came in.
You got the paperwork handy?
Why?
You got a pressing need to rummage through my private files?
Yeah.
I forgot you were keeping your lacy underthings in there.
Ooh la la.
Look, Jack.
I just want to see what they're charging for a crate of rifles these days.
Too damn much if you ask me.
Especially at the rate the assault teams are losing them.
I guess there ain't no harm in it.
What?
Can we get a new weapons shipment?
Yeah, Guza requisitioned a couple of cases for the assault teams.
Let me guess.
He's planning on taking out a small city.
Lieutenant's a big believer in overkill.
Okay.
Anything in the Asper room?
Uploading personal clue database.
Downloading mainframe clue database.
Confused.
Clue database transfer complete.
We still have just that one picture?
Yup.
We didn't get anything else.
I'm confused.
Let's try the autopsy guy.
See if he's got anything new for us.
Oh, no, he's not even here.
Ah, stop.
Geez.
Where is it?
The thing that...
The shipping form?
Is that what it was?
What's the point of having this as a clue if I can't even...
Look at it.
Save me, digital woman.
What's the point?
I can't even like, uh...
Observe it.
Like...
I guess I'll try going back to the animoid... role.
I don't know.
Try now.
Excuse me.
Ever consort with a group called CARS?
C-A-R-S?
CARS.
What is that?
Citizens against replicant slavery.
I don't have time for such pursuits.
How about Spencer Gregorian?
The same goes for him, whoever he is.
Funny.
Because he described you to a key.
I know, my gosh.
Even down to that stupid little ponytail you got.
It's called a chomagi.
What would you say if I told you Gregorian named you as one of the people who was there when the Tyrell building blew up?
There's a mistake somewhere along the chain of communication.
So, you're denying all involvement?
I won't lie to you, detective.
There was a time in my life when I might have been involved in such an organization.
I actually can.
But now, all I care about is my business.
I am nothing but a humble salesman.
Perhaps I can interest you in this camera.
The camera!
A hundred years ago, it was a cherished idea.
A hundred years ago.
I've seen plenty of photographs in my time.
I think cameras are still sought after.
Wow!
Flashbang!
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Take that.
And we're going after him, baby!
We're going after this guy!
Whoa!
Can I rob him blind?
Oh!
We're going down!
Uh-oh!
Oh!
This looks... not good.
Wait.
I'm exp... oh.
There were off-world rifles here and more.
Grenades, explosives, modern rifles, even some police issue restricted weaponry.
Izo wasn't some small-time fence, but a big-time arms dealer.
The exact arms that renegade replicants would be looking for to survive in the big city.
Ooooooo...
Okay, I think we...
This looks like it's...
It's...
What's the word?
Interactable, but...
Does not seem to be the case.
Okay.
Let's go with our...
With our gun out!
Come on!
Wait!
Oh!
Izo!
I'm ready to shoot!
I'm scared!
I'm scared, though!
I'm ready to shoot.
You come out!
I practice!
I have the highest score in the biz!
What is this?
Hmm.
Okay.
I have the highest score in the biz!
You don't wanna mess with me!
Has she saved?
Oh, I have, but I probably should save again, huh?
I'll save.
I remember this!
I remember this goopy area!
But I don't remember.
How are you supposed to...
You go that way, but how do you get over there?
Or in there.
Hmm.
Can't go this way.
Let's go through here.
That's...
Impossible.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Let's go this way.
Oh.
That's...
Impossible.
Guys, it's impossible!
Pizza!
Because you're the gifted!
Maybe a different way.
This way.
This...
Away.
Well, where did our little friend go?
I don't see anything to click on either.
That's...
Impossible.
The ladder.
Wait.
Where do you see that?
Ah!
Hmm.
Okay.
Just kidding.
What ladder?
You guys see a ladder?
You guys have such good eyes.
Where?
Shoot the lever!
It won't let me.
Top left?
That's...
Impossible.
Oh!
This right here!
My gosh!
I barely saw that.
How the heck did you guys see that?
Look at him go.
I am not about to have all my hard work obliterated.
Just because you stumbled into my shop, detective.
Westerners need guns and hardware.
I don't have my gun out!
All I need is...
This guy is just walking fast.
With this...
Freeze, Yoshi!
Easel.
Whatever.
Been keeping yourself busy?
I'll be out of lockup within the hour.
Your little skin job friend's gonna take up a collection to bail you out, or you got it saved up?
Maybe I got friends in high places.
Hello!
Yeah, and if my aunt had balls, she'd be my uncle.
What are you doing here, Slim?
I was gonna ask you the same thing.
I've been tracking this boy for a week.
He thinks he's pretty clever.
He's a material witness in a case I'm working.
In fact, your best buddy's a replicant, isn't he?
The big guy with the dreadlocks.
What's his name again?
Hallucinate often?
That's okay.
You'll be giving him up to me soon enough.
I can handle it from here, Slim.
Why don't you go buy yourself a lollipop?
Something else to suck on.
Very clever.
I'm the one who found him!
Oh, he's just going with her.
She didn't even lock him up.
He's just walking along with her.
Okay.
Does this badge mean anything to you?
Clearly not.
Well, damn.
I guess I will go get myself a lollipop.
Maybe...
Uh...
We can...
Dragonfly now.
Can we go to the lockup?
I think we can.
But before we do that...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What is this?
Oh, just kidding.
I thought it was something.
We grabbed a couple things too.
We grabbed the camera.
We grabbed some papers that were on the ground.
But everything...
I wish it was in the order of...
Of...
When you picked it up and not in alphabetical.
It's my birthday!
Synthesis, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the super chat!
Happy, happy birthday!
Uh...
Okay, maybe I...
Oh, source easel!
We got this picture.
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna start getting like...
I'm gonna steal.
Batch number BR61354.
Still working the explosion of the Tyrell manufacturing plant.
It'll take a day or so to analyze the debris, but there's no doubt in my mind that we're dealing with a bomb here.
One lollipop.
Right now, it looks like the protesters had nothing to do with it.
They were in too close proximity to have been in on Zeal.
No MO's or identities are rolling up just yet.
And I'm still going through the inset files to see if any replicate munitions experts are unaccounted for.
I'm gonna go through all the clues so that when we do get something new, we know it'll be lit up, you know?
The detonator wire I pulled out of his skull told the whole story.
But I wondered why the killer didn't just shoot him.
The dog collar has a name on it.
We have dog collar lowercase c and dog collar capital C.
Ricky's earring was shaped like an insect.
I didn't know much about jewelry, but it looked like junk.
While we do that, I'm gonna...
Okay.
Looks your rep swung that moon bus massacre last month.
They ever find the moon bus?
The moon bus.
Disappeared in the thin air.
Ryan thinks it crashed out in the kipple.
The kipple.
I'm gonna lower the volume so that you guys don't have to hear the beep.
Judging from the distance between the prints, I was looking for two very big men.
One dragged his right foot, indicating a possible injury or lameness.
The other appeared a lot more controlled, graceful even.
Quite a pair.
Kingston kitchens.
Where have I heard that before?
Most of them were shot point blank, but we're looking at some others.
Sloppy cuts with a knife.
Like the pert was really pissed off at something.
That black paint you found on the fire hydrant...
I remember this.
It's from a ground car.
This is Crystal Steel badge number BR-61354.
Conducting the interrogation of Spencer Gregorian.
Spencer Gregorian.
Who requires citizens against replicant slavery.
November 22nd, 2019.
I once again ask that my attorney...
Shut it, shitbird.
I'm asking the questions.
We've already put you on the machine, so we know you're not a skin job.
That term offends me.
Okay, so you're not one of those biomechanical scumbags.
You claim to not know anything about the bombing at Tyrell.
This is true.
We advocate equal rights under the law of the replicants.
This guy sounds like such nerds.
We have nothing against Tyrell Corporation for creating them.
Tyrell.
That's some sick logic.
The replicants are living organisms whether people like you like it or not.
Replicants contribute greatly to the economic well-being of our culture.
They cannot be discounted as such.
Hell, it'd be no skin off my nose if each and every one of them was hosed down for good.
You ever see this guy?
White.
Yes.
Actually, I have.
He was present at the protest.
He's not part of our group, but outsiders are usually welcome.
How many new faces showed up that day?
Not too many.
A handful at most.
Describe them to me.
I don't know if I can.
Oh, no?
Recording off.
Describe them for me again.
There was that Rastafarian fellow and one of our ex-members showed up.
Who's that?
A Japanese man named Izo.
Why'd you get rid of us?
We're a pacifist organization and we have rules.
One of them is no weapons allowed.
Oh, Izo broke that.
Izo refused to check in his samurai sword at the door during meetings.
Where can I find this Izo?
He owns one of those little second-hand stores downtown.
Izo has all the guns in the world and he was using his little samurai sword.
We have a number of anonymous donors.
People with resources and sources.
Such as?
So anonymous even I don't know who they are.
I almost believe you.
Let's check this out.
How long has that chef worked for you?
Zubin?
Just month?
Oh, yeah, we know this one.
Alright, hold on.
Pain transfer.
Peruvian lady.
Oh, we know this one.
There's a photo of McCoy.
That's the... Oh my gosh, we have a McCoy checky!
That's when he took in my picture right before he ran.
As a weeaboo, it is your duty to go back to Izo's room and confiscate his katana.
I think he took it with him.
Wait, is it actually in there though?
That'd be awesome.
Okay, this is this guy from the pet store.
We never found Lucy.
Lucy!
This game meshes the movie with the novel.
Kipple is the term from the book that means useless junk.
But all things wrought into.
Neat.
It was a Tyrell sales brochure for the Nexus series.
Tyrell.
Okay, yeah, we saw that.
The security photo.
We got that.
Okay.
So that's the weapons form.
That's what we...
And the weapons catch.
There were four rifles here and more.
Grenades, explosives, modern rifles, even some police issue restricted weaponry.
Okay.
Alright, so we've gone through all of our evidence.
But a big...
Very nice.
Let's go talk to her real quick.
And then...
Where are we going?
Rose, by definition, can never be skin jobs.
You are.
I have...
I have fake skin!
You hear anything yet about that dragonfly jewelry, like what I showed you before?
No, senor.
My friend, he's asking for me.
Do you know that David Cage said that the Troy become human was like Blade Runner, except we're supposed to sympathize with the robots.
Actually, I've been thinking about that game this whole time.
Digital green women tempt me.
We can be quite tempted.
I was fresh out of Leeds.
Poking around Hawker's circle had been a waste of time.
I had nothing to connect this Ezo character to the Eisenduller murder.
But if the replicants had done in one Tyrell scientist, maybe they'd go after another.
And the subcontractors down on DNA Row didn't have Tyrell's security to protect them.
A pet.
I love your voiceover.
So we're going to...
DNA Row, baby.
DNA.
I wonder what's here.
28 stabbing.
The ambience is so...
Why do I...
I feel a little anxious right now.
Oh.
We can go in there.
Oh, that's all where we can go.
Okay.
Let's go.
Not good time now.
Come back later.
Oh.
He's mumbling in Chinese.
Wait!
Hannibal too!
Is this Hannibal?
Can someone translate?
This has to be Hannibal.
He's looking for someone.
Is that what he's saying?
I'm looking around.
Wait.
Excuse me.
Oh.
Deliveries to Rare.
LPD, I got a couple of questions.
Hmm.
Talk, talk, talk.
Always talk.
You wake.
You don't take up time.
Busy, busy.
Talk, talk, talk.
Marcus Eisenduller is dead.
Uh, okay.
We talk.
Quick, quick, pal.
What you want?
Um, I want a...
You were close to Eisenduller?
Yeah.
Eisenduller?
Haha, no, no.
No time for him.
No go to a lab.
Eisenduller tests off world gravity.
Yeah.
To work important organs.
Visual center, you see?
Completely different.
Marcus is dead.
To work hard all night, all day.
No stop, no break, no OT.
Voice by James Hall.
Did you hear me?
Oh.
Of course I hear you.
You think I'm deaf?
Your time more important, huh?
Eisenduller dead.
Maraji may be dead.
You out chasing skirts.
Maraji?
You eat supper with Maraji.
Every night, no fail.
Sometimes Chinese, sometimes Indian, sometimes home cook.
Sometimes we go up and eat with twins.
Twins?
Maraji didn't show.
Did you call him?
Call?
No, I knock.
Ten minutes ago, door locked.
No answer.
Where'd you come from, huh?
What?
Nothing.
Huh?
Tell me this.
Hey, wait.
LPT.
You there for something, huh?
LPT?
I'm very busy.
Eis won't wait for nothing.
I'm a-a-a-b-b-b-b-b-the twins.
Okay.
Is that all we got?
Tell me this.
Hey, wait.
I'm very busy.
That's all we get from him.
Alright.
Interesting.
Uh, nothing else around here, I think?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, wait.
What's over here?
I can't read it.
It's so bright.
We can go up.
Or we can go through the front door.
Let's try the front door.
Ooh.
What's going on?
Who did this?
Oh.
Help me, sir.
Please, help me.
It is going to blow.
What's happening?
Who?
No, no, no!
Wait, what's hap- what?
What's gonna blow?
What's behind that door there?
Are you crazy?
That's a bomb on the chair.
Oh, there is?
This?
Wait.
Maybe I can disarm it.
No!
There is no time!
And he said, if you touch it!
Oh, it's gonna explode.
I didn't touch it.
Oh.
It was all a dream.
Should have taken the stairs.
So much for trying to be a good citizen and going through the front door.
Wait, but... Oh, gosh.
Where is it?
Where did it put me back at?
Now I think about it.
Hold on.
Let's run here.
And then... touch.
No!
All of my... wait.
Where am... what?
I don't know where it put us back.
Hold on.
Let me load.
We can probably load from the sewers.
I'd have to just backtrack a little bit here.
I think.
So here, this is right before we went up the ladder.
Okay.
I'll just skip it.
Yeah, we'll just speed through this part.
I am not about to have all my heart just...
Oh!
Freeze, Yoshi!
With his katana.
Can I talk to him?
No.
Okay.
Alright, now...
Um...
I go back...
Through here.
And we have our little inner monologue where we're like, I'm out of leads.
But first, I'm gonna grab a drink.
I think I deserve one.
Pour me one.
Just one?
Yeah.
One, but one good one.
I wonder if that actually costs money.
If I'm just blowing my savings at this place.
We'll never get Maggie a...
A partner.
Wait!
Is this katana in here?
For real?
14K!
I am the owner of the one and only 14K Laboobo.
Alright.
Once we get to...
DNA...
We'll talk to the one guy, and then I'll save.
Okey-dokey.
What's a labubu?
It's like a little plush.
Oh my gosh, I touched a labubu for the first time.
I was in Japan.
And my friend had one.
And I was like, oh my gosh, can I see her labubu?
She was like, it was a gift to me.
So I feel like, you know... How did it feel?
It was cute.
I actually kind of liked them.
Tell me that... Okay.
Alright, now... We go... Back.
Then over here.
And now I'm gonna save.
Okay, let's go upstairs.
I too prefer my women with green eyes.
My eyes are blue!
Blue no good for you?
Wait.
This thing moves, doesn't it?
Ah!
Shut up.
Yeah, I remember.
I recognized the logo on the envelope.
It was definitely Runciter's animal sales.
But I didn't expect to find hundreds of chin-yan inside.
I didn't know what it was for.
But I'd bet the farm it wasn't on Runciter's books.
This thing used to scare the crap out of me.
And I was a wee wisp.
So are we just gonna... We don't need to worry about the...
The bomb... If we're in here.
He says, yep.
You're okay to...
Oh, I broke it.
Oops.
I didn't know you could do that.
Is it gonna explode while we're walking?
That'd be crazy.
Okay.
Save again.
And
blow it up!
What's going on?
Who did this?
Help me, sir.
Please, help me.
It is going to blow.
You don't shoot the bomb.
What's going on?
Who did this?
Help me, sir.
Can I shoot right here?
Isn't this a...
Like a handcuff?
I'm clicking.
Run!
Oh!
Run?
Look at him go!
Oh, I got an achievement.
Escape the bomb explosion.
Let's go.
You good?
Hold on.
An ambulance will be coming.
You must warn the twins.
The twins!
It's good detective work, Lieutenant Minky.
Thank you!
The stairs.
The twins?
Did they do this?
No.
Tall bed with...
...redlocks.
The bomber.
The bomber!
And another with beard.
Wasn't the guy at the beginning with the beard?
Piercing eyes.
That was a big brain solution.
Hot dog.
Thanks.
TNA information.
Don't...
Oh, it's Moragy.
I just noticed.
Oh, you ratted him out.
Don't shoot.
McCoy, rep detect.
BR-61-661.
Sex...
Oh, dang.
What do you know about this?
Got a dead man here.
Victim of an explosion.
His name is, uh, was, Moragy.
He was able to give me a description of the two perks just before he bought the farm.
Yeah?
They skin jobs?
Or are you just in the right place at the wrong time?
I'm practically waxing their tails, officer.
I'm that close.
But I don't have a lot of time.
You mind, uh...
Mop it up here?
Just do me a favor and kick some rep ass, okay?
It's high time someone got them illegals off the street.
Appreciate it.
This is 32, sector 3, reporting a homicide.
Can you turn your mic down, Officer Grayford, please?
Goodness gracious.
You got a sheet or something we could cover him with?
Nah, nothing.
Cold Cup boys have been dragging ass.
Don't miss anything.
There ain't nothing left, detective.
Can we go back in there?
Oh, we can.
Wait, hold on.
Can I say it again?
Yuck.
So true.
Slappy.
Oh.
If my instincts were right, he was the same Joker who lit up the Tyrell building.
Dangerous, but still an amateur.
The plot keeps thickening like some sort of detective story.
Wee-woo.
Is there anything in here or has it all been blown to hell?
Locked.
No way through here.
You don't know that.
It was...
Hmm.
I guess not.
Okay.
Let's go upstairs to the twins, I suppose?
We were already up there, but he says to go again.
Slap.
Oh, this thing is still going.
Oh my gosh.
Scared me.
Oh, twins!
Twins!
The vid phone was one of those old Zenith jobs.
The last electronic tech that was still produced on this continent.
In Mexico, to be exact.
No wonder the sucker was on the blink.
Won't let me.
I wish I could shoot everything.
I thought that was like a person out there.
Yeah, that seems to be it in here.
Wait.
Hmm.
I never...
Nope.
Yep.
Oh, whoops.
Uh, click on me.
Okay, give me a second.
I'm going to go through these...
Wait.
The guy who set the bomb had been sloppy.
He kept the charge small enough to leave the wall.
Of course I hear you.
Yeah.
Uh.
This is Crystal Steel.
The detonator wire.
We already went through them.
I reckon...
I checked.
Judging from the distance between the print...
This is...
Describe them.
How long a king's...
Most of them had black paint you found on the fly hydrant.
Judging from the...
Oh.
No!
Okay.
The guy...
The bomber.
Scratches and paint.
See?
One at a...
She came to me with a ref...
And there's not a lot...
It was a...
Most of...
There were off-world rifles.
Okay.
There we go.
Sorry.
Now I feel like I'm safe scumming.
Um...
So it said warn the twins.
But how do I get to them?
But we also saw...
The thing about...
The animals.
So let's...
Oh.
Maybe we head back here.
Talk to Hannibal again.
I guess we...
I should have done that.
I thought about it and then I forgot.
Locked.
What still?
But there was evidence there.
We just had a bomb.
Who are you?
Wait.
Hey.
You killed anyone yet?
Go home and get some rest.
I'm sure you need it.
Why are you here?
Hey, that guy has a cane.
Wasn't one of the things that said there was a part here that killed the animals?
One guy had a limp?
In a game where completely random bombs blow you up, I think an occasional saving is more than justified.
Why is Gaff obsessed with killing Ryan?
Am I going to get ambushed here again?
I'm scared.
I can't trust anything here.
David, thank you so much for the super chat.
Don't feel bad about saves coming.
It helps consider how some relevant evidences and factors may change for a playthrough.
Thanks for helping me out, too.
I think he's...
I feel like he said go get some rest.
I'm going to go see if maybe we start act three.
If we sleep, you know?
Maybe if it'll...
Maggie!
Maggie, let me speak.
Maggie.
Good doggy.
Maggie, shut up.
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
She's hungry.
She's like, I haven't seen you all day.
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
There you go.
Okay.
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
I love how pixely he is compared to everywhere else in his apartment.
Okay, no.
Not act three yet.
Let's go talk to Hannibal.
Hannibal Chu.
Your floor number, please.
The portrait of an Epee boy.
Oof.
Going as best as a kid.
What makes Maggie special is that she might just be the only real dog in LA since pets are a luxury.
Well, she is now because all the pets at the...
At the animal...
The animal store were all murdered, so...
Yeah, probably now she is.
If the game tells you that the bomber's an amateur, then he's probably a human.
It says he's had military training and it's likely he's a replicant.
I saw someone mention that earlier.
How, like...
How...
Oh.
What you do, huh?
Hold on, I'll say after.
Oh, that, uh...
The game kind of randomizes who's replicants and who's humans?
So that each playthrough is a little different?
Like, that's so cool, no?
Listen to me.
Busy, busy.
You're not delivery man.
You go away.
A distraction all day long.
Never stop.
Loud noises on the street.
Beep, beep, bock, bock, bock.
Beep, beep, bock, bock, bock.ng Beep, beep, bock, bock, bock.
That'd be Dermo Design Burning to the ground.
Oh?
Beep, beep, bock, bock, bock.
What of Marazzi?
He didn't make it.
You leave now, okay?
Very busy.
Must work.
Uh,
twins.
You mentioned twins.
Yes, yes.
Luther and Lance.
Siamese twins.
Live about Miraji.
They're genetic designers?
Well, till last month.
Got the boot, the shit camp.
From who?
Big boss, who else?
Anybody tell them?
Go ask them.
I waste no more time.
You think I nose around everybody's business, huh?
Yeah, each playthrough is designed to be different, which is wild for a game.
Right?
Miraji.
Miraji's some kind of DNA designer?
Yeah, subcontractor like me.
He's funny, though.
Like old movies.
Miraji, master chef.
Wow.
Twins go crazy when he cooks.
What about this Lance?
What kind of guy is he?
Why, he's like Luther.
Only different.
Don't know which which.
That so?
One long hair.
Talk a lot.
Always make deals.
Other more quiet.
Work much harder.
Okay.
What kind of deals?
Sell this, sell that.
No matter what weather.
Like salesman.
Very hard to take.
No trust, no way.
Did Lance sell something to Runciter?
No.
Who?
Never heard of Runciter.
No time for charades.
Sound like this, sound like that, look like this.
Why is it weird to like old movies?
Right?
Sorry to bother you.
Okay, interesting.
Wait, oh, wait.
That's...
Hey, you killed anyone yet?
Why are you here?
This is... there's a dead man right here.
Oh, he's gone.
Just kidding.
Wait, so there's... there's... the twins still aren't up here?
I guess because they got fired?
Why is Gap here?
I'm telling you, he's suspicious to me.
Did I kill anybody yet?
That
guy at the very beginning of the game.
And now he's gone.
Okay.
Let's see.
Now do I go to Runciter's?
I'll try again, I guess.
Hmm.
I thought Gap was like a symbol that was just like, okay, now...
If I'm here, that means he goes to sleep.
I'm not on a pacifist run, I'm trying to kill.
Did you get the voice message about the twins?
I should've, yeah.
No way.
All my clues reset.
Oh no, just kidding.
Okay.
That's just how they look.
Um...
He talked about the twins.
Lance and Luther.
I don't see anything about it though.
So maybe I didn't.
What was the audio recording?
Wait.
I don't see anything about twins.
I don't see anything about Lancer and Luther.
Suspects list?
Yeah.
Uh...
Lucy.
Diesel.
That guy.
Someone responsible for animal murder and Moragia murder.
Just the animal murder.
This guy is the limping guy.
Zubin runs away.
Who's that?
Oh!
Zubin was the chef, I remember.
Hmm...
Central or Tyrell?
Yeah, we can try.
How did my dad figure this game out?
How?
I guess it's just a lot of...
Trial and going around and seeing what you need to do.
Look at him go.
In his little car.
I don't think...
I may have more questions for you later on.
Yes, sir.
No, nothing here.
PlayStation.
Yeah, I'm super eepy sleepy today.
It's okay, I can play a little bit more and then...
Maybe we'll finish it up tomorrow.
Ground floor.
Lock up.
Oh wait, lock up!
We were gonna go to!
Chu is voiced by James Hong.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Including the duck of Kung Fu Panda.
Also a military veteran.
Apparently he's 96 years old, wow.
Shido Neku-nya!
Thank you so much for the rito break!
Thank you!
You look right at home in there, Izo.
I've been in much tighter spots than this, McCoy.
I'll bet.
But this is only the beginning.
Izo!
Is this?
What's his name?
Are they letting me out?
Oh no, it's Gregorian.
I'm not the one who makes that decision.
I suppose it's my turn to bear the cross for the cause.
You're're Spencer Gregorian, right?
Hey Kaskey, kid.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Spank, thank you so much for the gifted!
He says, where is your motivation?
He's right there.
He's within your shot.
He's next to you!
You mean your neighbor?
Weapons to some of them.
What kind of weapons?
Guns so new that even the police had hardly used them, I heard.
That's so funny.
Hey, I'm right here!
Quit talking about me like I'm dead!
Ready to supply me some answers?
I wish I had something to say.
I know your hands are dirty, Izo.
Yeah!
Everybody in this world is trying to better himself.
No matter what the terms are.
If that counts as dirty, so be it.
The terms of your conviction won't be too clean.
I'll be through with this place long before you, McCoy.
Yeah, I'm sure you've been saving up for a rainy day selling all those illegal weapons.
One never knows when fate will conspire.
You must be prepared.
You're a real trooper, Izo.
Yeah, I love he's still got his little sword here.
On his back.
You look right at home in there, Izo.
That's really funny.
This guy had some other things.
Cars.
I got some more questions for you.
Lot of people involved in your cause, Spencer.
With such an attitude.
As more and more people realize that replicants have cognitive and emotional legitimacy.
The citizens against replicant slavery will spearhead the movement towards...
Save the pitch for someone who gives a shit.
We're peaceful people, detective.
We live by a code that men like you could never understand.
Try me.
Two centuries ago, humans were held in slavery.
Brave souls formed an underground railroad.
So, you help replicants escape the city.
I'm talking figuratively, detective.
Sure you are.
We're not children, detective.
We have resources.
The world is changing.
People are waking up to the injustices perpetrated by a sick society that you have helped...
A lot of them will wake up dead if reps are allowed to run amok on Tara, jerk.
Jerk.
I see.
V-V-Voy...Voy...Kampf.
I'm gonna give you a little test.
The other detective, she already tested me earlier today.
Oh, we're just giv-we're all givin' out tests on.
Uh-huh.
Look, I gotta check out the equipment, and you're the only stiff around.
I object to this treatment.
If you'll just call my lawyer, he'll take care- Your lawyer would tell you I got the authority to VK the mayor, if I want.
What does that mean?
And he'd have to smile and nod and kiss my butt until I cleared him.
So sit down.
He's gonna kiss her-oh!
Administero!
Oh, I got the...the test!
What the hell is this?
Human reaction gauge.
Adjust the calibration.
I'm doing something and I don't know what I'm doing.
Uh...
Oh, I see, I see.
Ask a medium intensity question.
Oh my...
What the hell is going on?
Happy 10th anniversary of VK just getting in early.
Ha-ha-ha!
Decorate, thank you!
A-ha.
Reaction time is a factor in this, so please pay attention.
What?
Where do you live?
Third sector.
Uptown.
Nice neighborhood?
Very.
Is this going to take long?
Just keep your pants on, Spencer.
I don't even know what's happening.
German fur without suffering.
It's a test to elicit an emotional response.
Replicates can be caught through this.
Oh!
It was invented by the Soviets according to the novel.
Whoa!
I don't...
I wish I knew anything that was happening.
You've been drafted into the army.
During a boot camp hazing, you're bound, blindfolded, and forced to eat worms.
Worms!
Hazing's illegal.
Oh, yeah.
You're really worried about breaking the law.
Wonder why I'm the one on this side of the bars.
Civil disobedience has a long history in our world.
So does genocide, but I ain't out butchering my neighbors.
I think this guy is human, though, but, like, I'm also very confused just what is happening.
You're at a restaurant with friends.
One of them orders lobster.
The chef drops the lobster into the tub of boiling water while you watch.
No!
Are you trying to make me sick?
Out of the corner of your eye, you see a large black spider crawling up the wall.
I'd call animal services, of course.
I wouldn't try to move it myself, not without proper equipment.
I'm sorry.
You're calling animal services for a spider?
Huh?
You know what?
Valid.
Like my briefcase?
Department issue.
Baby hide.
100% genuine human baby hide.
Appropriate.
For a killer.
I don't know if we should be mentioning that.
Is that something we should be mentioning to anybody?
Is it from the babies I shot?
What?
He's trying to get a reaction from Moses.
It's quite the question, no?
Ground floor.
That's why me and Toa were shooting babies earlier.
For my briefcase.
We got a whole bunch of new recruits, guys.
We gotta...
We gotta get them...
ready.
Yeah.
Um...
I'm going to consult the...
the...
the walkthrough.
Go through the alley next to the eye lab.
Oh wait!
There's our guy!
Go home and get some rest.
I'm sure you need it.
Gaff is everywhere.
A happier note...
than baby hide.
Today is national ice cream day!
I want ice cream!
I want ice cream.
Okay.
So...
Roof.
We go...
There was a...
there was a la...
an alleyway by the...
by the eye lab?
In DNA Row?
Oh?
I guess I missed it.
Mochira on daisuki...
Ai sukurin!
Alley, wait...
Is it...
I'm guessing this is the eye lab.
Here?
Go through the alley next to the eye lab.
Look out!
Oh!
Here!
Maybe!
Oh my god...
Oh no.
Just kidding.
Me too!
That's me!
Called Blade Brother so far, we've only seen one guy with a sword and he walked away with it.
There was an alley...
somewhere, apparently.
I am being told there's an alleyway in the walkthrough.
I fear I'm being lied to.
What?
What'd you do, huh?
What did I do?
Sorry to bother you.
Go into a mini cafe, your own little rice is inside out, and the latte art reads poison.
What do you do?
They won't let me go over here.
If there's an...
What?
It says there's something here that we're supposed to enter.
To get us to Act 3, but I can't figure it out.
This game is a little obtuse.
Sorry guys.
It says you should go after...
After...
Um...
The bomb.
Point and click is always like that.
Adventure games are like that?
Yeah, they can be.
Uh...
It does say something about a Kia.
Like doing the Kia again.
So let's do that.
Oh my gosh!
Guzz...
He's here again!
Let's go back.
Uh...
Which would be faster?
The apartment maybe?
Let's try.
I'm looking out for any ambushers.
So far we've only killed one guy.
I always keep the guide handy.
I try not to.
Your floor number please.
But...
McCoy, 88F.
88.
Thank you.
The new has me worried about Ray.
What?
Is it killing lately?
Maggie!
Okay.
So we had a new photo I believe.
Which is what it wants us to investigate.
This one.
I think.
China bar.
Yes!
So maybe this will...
Activate something.
Tooth game played by a cute maid.
Ah!
Whoa!
Is that Izo?
Oof!
That guy sure gets around.
Give me a hard copy of that.
Wait, who is that guy?
What about the lady?
What about our little lady friend?
Enhance.
Enhance?
Hold on, sorry, I'm reading the guide again.
Haha!
Zoom on the head of the guy talking to the woman at the blonde bar.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
I wonder if there's anything in the picture of us.
Wait, how do I get back to that?
Oh, here we go.
This one.
Yeah!
Computer enhance on the lady in the bottom... bottom left?
Peach posting?
Peach?
No comment?
Enhance!
Oh gosh!
The other left.
What a face.
Face only Maggie could love.
Okay, well we got this thing.
I don't think there was anything else in the china bar.
I don't think so.
Except a pretty lady.
Who's this handsome devil?
Ha ha ha ha.
McCoy, are you?
Is that you?
Your floor number, please.
Maybe that will activate where we need to go.
Oof.
Maybe.
Ha!
Alright.
Where was that bar, anyway?
It just said China bar.
I'm gonna go back to DNA row, because that's what the walkthrough tells me to do?
But for some reason, I think that it's not going to change much.
I might... hopefully I'm wrong.
Ah!
Where is the alleyway?
That we need to go to?
Thank you.
This is the i...
lab.
No!
Upstairs, twins, phone answering machine.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Get out of here, you freak!
Why are you stalking me?
Did I not get the phone?
Or the...
I thought there was something on the computer I got.
I'll check again though.
Gaff is everywhere.
Let me do my job.
You can't be hovering over me like this forever.
Hmm.
Oh, maybe it's this!
Hello, Luther.
Hello, Lance.
You have no new messages and one saved voice-only message.
Would you like to hear the saved message again?
Absolutely.
Hello, it's JF Sebastian.
I hope you guys are alright.
Sebastian.
I tried to talk to Dr. Terrell about, uh, about your reinstatement.
Re-employment.
Yeah.
But I haven't been able to get through to him yet.
He's kinda angry and you know what a cool customer he is.
I don't know what happened between you guys, but I'm still trying.
There is a doll maker in this.
If you want to get together, I'm still at the Bradbury.
I'll be here all night.
That's at the Bradbury!
Message saved automatically.
To delete, please state your deletion security number.
Not right now.
8-0-0-8-5.
The pleasure is all ours at Sino Bell.
Okay.
Nice!
Alright, let's go meet our guy at the Bradbury.
He always walks so slowly there.
Okay.
Yay!
That should activate it.
Thank you for, um, whoever told me about the...
Oh, but it doesn't.
Eh?
Maybe the Bradbury is in our car.
Maybe the Bradbury is the friends we made along the...
Ah!
He scared me again!
Bradbury!
This is so tiny, by the way.
The DNA roll.
Maybe let's go talk to somebody.
Oh!
Wait!
You still hanging around?
Who is that?
What?
Wait, who was that?
Ray, go into the Brad...
Hey, pal.
What's shaking, baby?
Oh, it's Gordo!
Haven't I seen you around these parts before?
Could be.
I get around.
He was the guy at the bar.
You ever get down to Nightclub Row?
You ought to check out my act.
Nightclub Row?
I'm just...
Warming up the room.
But it's better than a kick in the pants, ya dig?
What?
What kind of stuff do you do?
What kind of...
You kidding, baby?
I do it all!
It does it all!
I am the direct extension of Frankie, Sammy D, and Dino Martini.
Wow.
Who?
Man, you really must be dozing in Squaresville.
So, if you're asking who the voice is, you know, old Blue Eyes.
The chairman of the board?
Yeah.
Sinatra, man.
Frankie!
The guy's been dead for 20 years.
Well, you're gonna remember the name Gordo Frizz, just like old Blue Eyes.
Gordo Frizz.
I ain't on the Marquis of Earlies just yet.
But it's coming.
I promise ya.
20, that's it?
I know, right?
You know anything about that bomb that just rocked the street?
Bombing?
I've never bombed in my life.
My act is always happening.
Always now.
Cut to shit.
The man was killed back there.
Gee, that's a drag.
There's eight million stories in the Naked City, you know?
Gordo!
And you know nothing about it.
Sali, Charlie.
Hey, Gordo, how do I get to the...
How do I get to the...
The hotel?
It's telling me to go...
Not good time now.
Come back later.
Can you...
Can you help me get to...
I'm lost!
Please, sir.
I need...
Directions.
It's still mumbling.
In Chinese.
What's Sebastian been up to lately?
Oh, okay.
Here we go.
Sebastian?
You do what always do.
Nervous system.
Very important to Dr. Terrell.
Where do I find him?
He had an old building down the alley.
Oh, here we go.
Bradbury Hotel, I think.
You walk down the alley, you find it.
Yeah!
Guy's my new roll bottle.
Sorry to bother you.
I...
I can't get over that.
You know anything about the bomb?
Bomb?
I never bomb.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
We did it.
Yay!
Is this it?
The Bradbury?
Creepy.
Here we go.
Progress!
Oh my gosh!
Is this...
This place is still...
Functional, no?
This is a place where people still...
reside?
Oh,
I remember this thing!
It was some kind of freakish toy.
Oh!
Half mechanical, half organic.
Ref technology for sure.
Oh my gosh.
But no one was gonna give me any retirement bonus for it.
I did not like this guy.
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
I remember this thing.
Oh my gosh!
I hate...
Hate, hate, hate.
Oh my gosh.
It's...
Where?
Uh...
So freaky.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh, I don't like him.
Oh gosh.
Getting all the flashbacks.
I didn't have time to stop for synthetic eggs.
I remember tasting a real one back when I was a kid.
It was like liquid sunshine.
Damn tasty.
I love eggs.
Oh...
This place is kind of freaky, no?
More useless junk.
Right...
Useless junk.
Oh my god.
This is so freaky.
Oh, what's this?
Presuming interrupted print job.
Beep!
Nothing more to find.
What did they print?
Maybe...
Uh...
This over here?
DNA research.
Incept dates.
A lot of jargon.
But I bet my spinner it was valuable to somebody.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
It was some kind of freakish toy.
Half mechanical, half organic.
Rep technology for sure.
But no one was going to give me any retirement bonus for it.
Oh...
There's two of them.
There's two of them!
Oh my god.
I forget I remember...
Oh.
I remember...
I remember hitting this place.
I remember all this water.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Let me save the game.
I'm scared.
What is that?
Is that something?
No.
We're just... Wow, we actually just vandalized the place.
It had nothing of value at all.
Okay.
Anything?
No?
Oh wait, we can go up.
Oh, it made a ladder.
Oh gosh.
I'm
getting my ass beat.
Uh oh.
He's kicking me.
What do you do, Sadiq?
Enough.
Stop taking me.
One of the design subcons must have talked.
Unstable personalities, to say the least.
For you, we should have blown up the old block.
It would have created problems down the line.
We got problem Nauma.
This one?
He's not a problem.
He's an opportunity.
Ooh.
You're weak, my friend.
I expected so much more from you.
Are you gonna blow me up?
I'm thinking our brother not hearing too good.
Oh, he hears us.
Yeah, cause he kicked me in the ear.
Isn't that right, McCoy?
You ready to give up fruitless nightmare man?
You know my name.
Come back to family?
He doesn't have a choice.
Huh?
He never did.
Oh!
Rich Act 3!
We did it!
Let me kill him, man.
No.
We got no time to be patient.
Your woman, she be getting sick.
I promise you, she'll not die here on Earth.
He looks like... I promise somebody will.
Like a 2000s... like emo band singer.
Something dangerous.
A fool sees not the same tree a wise man sees.
I'm no fool, man.
You must have a little faith, my friend.
Without contraries is no progression.
How can you trust any of their kind?
We have been manipulated by them, correct?
Or he looks like a backstreet.
One of the backstreet boys.
Now they're going to see exactly what lies on the other side of the horizon.
Whoa!
Worm!
That's on the horizon?
Catch me if you can!
What?
It's Lucy!
Atomic bomb!
What just happened?
Lucy!
How long have I been here, Lucy?
How do you know my name?
I saw your things at Runciter's.
Did you feel bad when they killed those animals?
They were so pretty and sweet.
I hoped father wouldn't do it.
But Mr. Runciter deserved retribution.
That's what father said.
Okay fair, but...
The animals were innocent.
He treated me...
Bad.
Like I belong to him.
I'm sorry.
Are you really the hunter?
Like father says?
It's my job.
Why?
What do you have against us?
Nothing.
It's just...
The law.
Would you hurt me?
I promise you I won't.
But it's the law.
You just said.
What?
Father will be back soon.
Is that it?
There I feel like we did not explore that place so much.
I feel like there's some other things that I didn't look around.
You know?
Um.
But that's okay.
Let's see.
What do we got here?
Oh, there's a little doll.
Um.
Hold on.
One second.
Oh.
Trying to see.
Okay.
So we're...
So apparently there's five acts.
We're on act three.
So I think maybe...
Tomorrow...
We can...
Finish the rest.
That's what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
I might cut it here just because I'm still feeling a little...
I'm still feeling a little bleh.
So...
Hmm.
I think this is a good spot to end it probably.
Probably.
But uh...
I still have to make my...
Finish my schedule.
For the week.
But...
Either tomorrow or the day after.
I'll...
I'll figure it out.
Because I have a meeting.
Um.
Here's a $50 bribe to consider the nice guys for next watch along.
And that...
Wait isn't...
Wait.
I think I talked to...
Oh yeah, yeah.
We talked about that...
That video.
That movie.
Recently.
Thank you.
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you so much, Drake.
Um.
Thank you for your help today too.
Thank you guys for helping me out with some of the parts when I was getting stumped too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Um.
We'll finish it this week though.
We'll finish...
Uh...
Blade Runner.
Sometime this week.
Either tomorrow...
Or sometime else.
Yeah.
But um...
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Um...
And...
We'll probably unlock so many core memories tonight.
I...
Just seeing some of these things.
I would be like...
I...
I recognize this.
And I recognize that.
I recognize...
It was so crazy!
Going and seeing all these...
These places that I'm like...
Whoa, wait a second.
I actually...
I know this for real!
It's crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
And there were some parts where I was like...
I could very vividly remember it.
Like the...
Like the pet store.
But...
Some parts that I was just like...
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I completely forgot about this.
But I hope you guys have been enjoying Blade Runner.
And we can finish it up and...
Finish up the mystery and everything.
So...
Thanks for the streaming though.
Thank you!
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Thanks for watching with me.
I really, really appreciate it.
Always fun to see you play games outside of current trends.
I try.
I...
I try to play a...
A...
Variety, you know?
So...
Thank you for the buzzer.
It was a nice nostalgia trip.
Hope you get...
You get...
Rest, feel better.
Thank you!
Eat ice cream.
Don't kill babies.
Or...
Kill ice cream.
Eat babies.
Make babies into your briefcase.
Baby hide.
Baby hide because you're about to be made into a briefcase.
True.
Yeah, true.
Make babies?
Otsubito!
Thank you, everybody!
Itte rasha!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Itte rasha!
Bye bye!